don't make a plan that is what you
should do make a plan that outlines a
future so that you can sit back and say
look if I had that future then all the
horrible things that are going to happen
to me are going to be worthwhile that's
what you want do you want to think this
game is worth playing despite its
tragedy that's what you've got in life
enough meaning to serve as an antidote
to tragedy and then you generate a
strategy the other thing you should do
if you're not very industrious is
discipline yourself eat three times a
day at regular meal times that's a good
thing to practice because that starts to
put some stability into your life get up
at the same time I would highly
recommend all those young people out
there who are listening you want to get
a jump on life get the hell out of bed
in the morning as I've got older I've
got up earlier and earlier now that's
partly because you don't need as much
sleep but it's also partly because I've
got more and more discipline get up
early in the morning and get your things
done learn to get up at six in the
morning and you'll be one deadly
creature especially if you can get to
work you'll have half your damn day done
and so that's a massive massive
Advantage hey it's Evan Carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you too you've got Michael Jordan level
genius at something so today let's live
your best belief life and get some
incredible motivation from the one and
only Jordan Peterson
look Will Ferrell Warren Farrell not the
comedian Warren Farrell the author he
outlined data in why men earn more which
is a book I would recommend by the way
showing that if you work 13 longer hours
you make 40 percent more money
it's non-linear so you think why is that
well imagine you had 10 employees and
one of them Works an extra 10 percent
it's not much well how often is that
person going to be
promoted assuming you have a clue as a
boss it's like you're going to look at
the 10 people and you're going to think
oh that guy's always here like 45
minutes early it's like why don't we
give him the promotion obviously right
so these tie these small edges that you
can manage like that work an extra 10 or
extra 13 percent have non-proportional
payoffs that's part of the Pareto
distribution so
get
get your sleep cycle organized so you
get up in the morning learn how to do it
no excuses I'm too tired in the morning
I don't like mornings who cares that's
not relevant it's like discipline
yourself so you can manage it
schedule your meals because that's a
good disciplinary routine
and then learn to use a calendar like
Google Calendar most of you many of you
out there do not use a calendar okay a
calendar is not a prison and it's not a
tyrant not if you use it properly
a calendar keeps anxiety at Bay it makes
sure that you do what you need to do
which is important because otherwise you
fall behind but if you use it properly
though it's also helps you plan what you
want to do so I could say well lay out
your damn calendar
and design the days you would like to
have that's what your calendars have is
for so you can put in all sorts of
things in there you want to do and that
would be good for you and that's a
really good a really good way to start
being more industrious make a plan you
need a plan for three years
you need a plan for the next year you
need to plan for the next six months you
need to plan for the next three months
you need a plan for the week you need a
plan for the day you need a plan for the
hour all of that all of that I make
lists constantly of what I have to do
and they're like daily weekly monthly
yearly right now I can't look out more
than about six months you know because
my life is too complicated and chaotic
but but you need a vision of who you
could be what character you could have
three to five years out you can't go
much farther than that because life is
too unpredictable I think to make Vision
that's longer term than that
subject to
there's too much chance associated with
it to spend a lot of time on maybe you
can stretch it to five years and in rare
cases you can have a 10-year goal but it
has to be pretty low resolution but you
want plans at all those levels of
resolution you want to write the things
down and what because what are you going
to do you're going to stumble around and
get get what you need you're going to
stumble around and be useful to other
people and it's useful to be useful to
other people you know they want to work
with you then they want to do things
with you they want to have you around
they trust you they open up
opportunities for you and if you stumble
around like you're blind you're not
going to get anywhere and then you're
going to suffer and then you're going to
be bitter and then you're going to be
cruel so that's a bit that's hell that's
a bad outcome so unless you want that
don't aim for it and or or aim for the
opposite because that's how you get out
of it you should treat yourself like
you're someone responsible for helping
and the first question is well why don't
you and the answer is
well there's a lot wrong with you
you know and it's hard to
exercise enough love
and Care in a deep and non-naive way to
care properly for something like that
it's an encouragement
to assume to act out the proposition
that even if life is as difficult
as it seems to be and if you're as
vulnerable and weak in a fundamental
sense as you definitely are and
characterized by this terrible
propensity for the infliction of
voluntary suffering on yourself and
others and that destructive tendency
that there's still something within you
that's so remarkable and so
aligned with
with order and being in the proper
manner that you can climb above that
let's say like Abel and that you can
make the proper sacrifices and that you
can set yourself right and you can set
your family right and you can set the
world right and that the mere
possibility that that might occur that
that might be within the realm of
potential means that you have a moral
obligation to exercise the
responsibility to take care of yourself
as if you're something that matters and
that if you did that properly it might
turn out that what you did would matter
that it would matter to you that it
would be meaningful in the way that
things that matter are meaningful and
that it would matter to everyone around
you so I would say well without Free
Speech there's no true thought and then
you might say well who the hell cares
whether or not we think and I think the
answer to that is fairly straightforward
I mean you might think it's so obvious
that it doesn't need explanation but
there are very few things that are so
obvious they don't need explanation so
the reason you think is so that the
world doesn't smack you as hard as it
might fundamentally you know and I
really mean this technically because the
way that people evolve the capacity to
thought for thought was that the
prefrontal cortex which mediates a lot
of of voluntary linguistic ability
actually emerged over the course of
evolutionary history out of the motor
cortex and so that's a very interesting
thing to understand because it means
that you know animals basically think by
moving and the problem with that is if
you think by moving and you make the
wrong move then you're dead whereas what
human beings can do is they can generate
fictional avatars of themselves in
fictional worlds and they can run the
avatars as simulations and the ones that
get killed they don't Express in
behavior and I mean you could do that
with words too although people you know
originally would have done it mostly
with images they do the same thing with
drama and so the reason
that you think and I think it was George
was it Alfred North Whitehead that said
this I think but I'm not absolutely sure
the reason you think is so that your
thoughts can die instead of you and
that's a Brilliance it's a brilliant
brilliant phrase and and absolutely the
case so if you think properly then you
kill off the ideas that if you acted out
would kill you or at least cause you
suffering or perhaps cause suffering to
the people around you and since it's
more or less obvious a priori that
suffering is worse than not suffering
under most circumstances it seems
reasonable to act in a manner that will
minimize it to the degree that that's
possible and so you need Clarity of
thought because that helps guide you
through a world that's enshrouded in fog
and full of sharp objects and if you
don't want to stumble into them and
impale yourself then you should have
sharp vision and sharp capacity to
communicate you know that's one of the
things I tell students when I'm trying
to teach them to right because they no
one ever tells them why they should
learn to write it's like you learn to
write so you can think and you learn to
think so that the world doesn't treat
you any more harshly than it absolutely
has to and that's no joke you know and
if you if you're a person who's been
around a bit you see very rapidly that
people who sharpen their arguments
properly and can articulate their
position and defend it are always always
the people who are most successful and
most compelling and that and that change
the way structures function and and that
also help things continue in the proper
path when they're running down the
proper path it's no joke to be
articulate and to be able to think there
isn't anything that's more powerful than
that
and that's a good segue into the second
or the third part of what I wanted to
talk to you about
see
since I made those videos uh I've become
I guess the word is popular
on yeah well in many ways by about
November by the end of November last
year there were more than 200 newspaper
articles about the consequences of the
videos that I'd produced and I and those
were like in press printed articles I'm
not talking about anything that happened
on YouTube and YouTube is a very strange
phenomenon that let me tell you it's a
far more powerful than you think so just
as an aside I was on a program last week
hosted by a guy named Joe Rogan I don't
know how many of you know who Joe Rogan
is Joe Rogan gets 1.2 billion downloads
of his podcasts a year you just think
about that like that's absolutely
unparalleled and everybody under 30 is
getting their news from either Facebook
or from YouTube and the whole
conventional media sources their debt is
they're so dead you can hardly believe
it so YouTube and one of the reasons I'm
bringing it up is because YouTube is the
first platform that's produced for
people the capacity to make the spoken
word as far-reaching and permanent as
the written word right that's a complete
cultural revolution it's the first time
it's ever happened I mean it wouldn't
have to be YouTube it just turns out
that that's the platform that got there
first but it's a big deal
and anyways
um
the re the reason that that that my that
I became popular I think was partly
because of the of the political
philosophical videos that I made but
then when people came to my website to
watch them they stayed generally
speaking to watch the lectures that I
had been posting on there since 2013.
and uh
those were derived from work I did on a
book called maps of meaning which I
published in 1999 and you see what I was
trying to do with that book was to sort
something out that was very complex and
that was
when I was growing up and the cold war
was raging
I I couldn't understand precisely why we
had divided into two armed camps around
our respective ideological positions
either why those ideological positions
were so important that people would risk
the destruction of the world to protect
them let's say or why it was those two
particular ideologies or whether or not
this was just a difference of opinion
right which would be that would be a
more post-modern view is there's
multiple ways that you can organize
Societies in the west we happen to
organize our society one way but that's
one of a plethora of potential ways of
organizing society and let's say the
Communists had decided to organize their
society another way and human beings are
infinitely malleable and so you know the
social structures that we occupy are
arbitrary in some sense and matter of
opinion and maybe Collective opinion but
nonetheless still a matter of opinion
and I thought well is it the case that
the values that we hold to be true in
the west are merely based upon opinion
and so I started to investigate that and
and the conclusion that I came to as a
consequence of hitting the question from
multiple different perspectives was that
that was not a reasonable way of
formulating of of of interpreting the
evidence and so I looked at neuros
evidence from neuropsychology and
Neuroscience mostly mostly uh
based at least in part on the work of
someone named Jeffrey gray it was a very
good psychologist very interested in
anxiety I looked at
General behavioral psychology looked at
literature and I looked at mythology
and I could see a pattern emerging
across all of those which I think is a
nice way of determining whether or not
something exists like it's one thing to
see a pattern in one set of data but if
you can see the same pattern in another
set that's quite historically distinct
from the first and then see the same
pattern in another set and then another
set then the probability that that's a
spurious pattern starts to decrease
quite radically pick something aim at it
as you move toward it you'll get wiser
then maybe your aim will change that's
okay but at least it'll change in an
informed way
it's like discipline yourself in one
dimension
see what happens
well that's exciting
and I think that's something that's open
for everyone
you can do that I shouldn't say that
because I don't believe that I think you
can find yourself in situation that's so
dire that you don't there's no escape
from it
but that doesn't matter because this
still this is the hero myth might not be
the best we have might not always work
but it's still the best we have
and the fact that it might not work
doesn't mean we should throw it away
it's still the best we have I mean
everyone dies and so we fail in some
sense
the fact that a symphony ends doesn't
mean that it wasn't worth listening to
you look where you think it's important
to look
so I'll say that again you look where
you think it's important to look and
that means that while a hierarchy of
importance is no different than a
hierarchy of value they're the same
thing a hierarchy of priority is the
same as a hierarchy of value and a
hierarchy of priority and a hierarchy of
value and an ethic are all the same
thing right because you're going to look
at what you believe to be of cardinal
importance
otherwise you look well if you're
talking to someone and you look at their
feet
that's not going to be going very well
right first of all they're not going to
be very impressed with you because they
actually want you to look at their eyes
and that's because we communicate value
with our eyes and we do that directly
our eyes have even involved to do that
our eyes have whites around the iris so
that you can see where people Point them
because it's that important to know what
people think is important we see the
world through a structure of value
and I think that a huge part of that
structure of value is actually derived
from the entire set of texts entire set
of texts and they're into relationship
that have the biblical Corpus at their
base and so it seems to me that you I
think you can make a pretty damn strong
case
maybe on scientific grounds that you
can't see the world except through the
lens of the Bible
like literally you actually can't see it
now if it's not the Bible it might be
some other Corpus of texts but it might
be it isn't
and if it was well is it going to be a
corpus of text that we share because if
it isn't then we can't share our
perceptions and our values and if we
can't share those then we fight those
are the options right we either
stabilize our hierarchies of value in
some way that we agree upon mutually or
we fight that's or we're unbelievably
chaotic and confused and that'll just
produce fighting in any case and so
we have this structure of texts built
from the bottom up it's predicated on
the biblical narratives
and the texts exist in relationship to
those underlying narratives and derive a
fair bit of their meaning from the
meaning of the underlying narratives and
and vice versa you know
um
and so then the biblical is it possible
that biblical truth is the sort of truth
that is the precondition for truth
right because you think well it's
religious people make the claim people
of the Bible make the claim the Bible is
true well there's all sorts of different
kinds of truth that's that's an
interesting claim but it's not very
elaborated it's it's insufficient
um and you know often what happens to
Christians when they debate skilled
atheists like Richard Dawkins is they
treat the Bible like it's a scientific
theory and darkness just mops the floor
with them because it's actually not a
scientific theory compared to scientific
theories and so as soon as you go there
well it's like a scientific theory it's
like no it's not it's not and so does
that mean it's not true well it means
that if the only thing you think is true
is a scientific theory
but
I don't think that you can practice
science except within an ethical
framework that's not in itself science
and so it's possible that there is a
deeper truth than the scientific truth
which is the ethic that has to be their
a priority before you can even begin to
do science we should make much more of
an effort to ensure that kids are
unbelievably proficient readers and a
lot of that is going to involve early
automatization of letter and phoneme and
syllable and word recognition so because
what happens is
when you teach a child to read first of
all you teach them the alphabet and the
sounds and we have an alphabetic
language thank God because it makes
things much simpler and so you teach
them the letters and then the two letter
combinations and then the three letter
combinations then they can sound out
syllables and then they get words but it
isn't until you can read phrases
automatically at a glance that you can
read for content and pleasure
and so a lot of kids get stuck
especially if they don't come from
particularly literate homes where where
all of this is sort of taught you know
maybe starting at
you know 12 months when they're first
dragging a book around and and becoming
familiar with the book as an object
right before they even learn to read
you got to get kids through that
automatization phase and that requires
intense Mass practice and that's not
that intrinsically interesting right but
if you can get them to the point where
they can read for Content well then it
starts to become interesting just as
interesting let's say as going to a
movie or perhaps playing a video game
and so that has to be made an absolute
priority and and the far if the
faculties of Education were doing their
job they would have produced technology
to solve that problem for virtually
every child because it is only a matter
of practice smarter kids will learn
faster but with enough practice pretty
much everybody is going to get there
so and then there's the marketing issue
it's like well why should you read well
do you want to be stupid
you want to be stupid what happens when
you're stupid you walk into walls
because you don't see them and if
someone comes along who's more educated
than you more literate and canier
they'll just
you'll lose man you'll lose and you'll
lose too because you can't think
properly so you won't aim at the right
things and you won't be informed by the
great individuals of the past and you
need that we're historical creatures
this isn't optional
so part of it has to be
marketing for lack of a better word it's
not really that it's an explanation why
be literate
because it makes you
it helps you become who you could be
helps you move out into the world and
have your Great Adventure
and to bring people along God only knows
what you can do if you've got your words
lined up properly
and young men would listen to that if
someone who knew what they were talking
about was telling them that
as you found out if you've explicitly
formulated a set of goals and you're
pursuing them then you've adopted the
responsibility to act in a certain
manner to make those goals realize
themselves that's
that's responsibility that you've
adopted rather than
responsibility that's been imposed on
you assuming that you've thought through
the goals and you find your spirit in
harmony with those goals
you can consult your resentment I think
that's a very useful step if you find
yourself angry and bitter about the
things that you are responsible for
doing then that's an indication that you
might be operating under some
unhealthy compulsion
that you're rebelling and that's the
reason for the resentment against the
insistence that you act in a certain way
although it's also possible that you're
just immature and that you're rebelling
against the discipline that's necessary
to attain the goals that you genuinely
do want to attain and that are valid and
that you are
what actively engaged in constructed
so you have to get that straight and
some of that's a consequence of thought
and again some of that's a consequence
of of discussion with other people
with whom you're
intimate enough to have a conversation
like that and perhaps they have
conversations about similar things with
you if you're fortunate at the end of
God's creation describing how order
emerges from chaos or being from
potential there's this strange line
which is probably the most important
line that's ever been written
in our culture at the basis of our
culture and that is that men and women
are made in the image of God and what
does that mean well if God is that which
confronts potential with truth and
courage and makes what's good out of
potential that seems to indicate that we
have the same faculty like on a smaller
scale we're not omniscient but we're not
bloody well nothing you know our our
conscious is integrally tied into the
structure of being in some manner we
don't understand and it certainly is the
case that we take what isn't and turn it
is into what is that's something man
that's that's quite the trick we've been
able to manage and so we're made in that
image and so what are we supposed to do
well that's what we're supposed to do
we're supposed to type our letters and
make our phrases and construct our
sentences and build our paragraphs and
put our
chapters together and make our books and
communicate to people and straighten out
the damn culture and constrain the
malevolence and ignorance that besides
each of us and push nature back and
extend ourselves out into the unknown
and confront the potential that's there
in the illimitable quantities and make
the world better than it could be
otherwise to Move It Away From Hell
which and it can certainly become that
and toward heaven to the degree that we
can manage that and that is a good
enough goal that's the thing you need
something you know because your life is
tough It's hard you need something that
you know you need something to get out
of bed for and fight for and that's
something right to fight let's say
against hell and for heaven
that's something to fight for is
especially
and you know if you if you don't if you
want to be convinced about this like
read a little bit about hell read the
gulag archipelago or read ordinary men
or read the rape of Nan King or read
about what happened in Nazi Germany
during Auschwitz and all the
catastrophes of the 20th century and see
if you believe in hell and see if you
think well maybe not having that happen
anymore would be a good idea and then
think about maybe that's something you
could contribute to
and then it wouldn't have to happen
anymore
and that would be a good thing and God
only knows what great things we could
manage under such conditions we're
becoming incredibly technologically
powerful and what would it be if we
became what would it be like if we
became equally wise
well that would really be something God
only knows what we could manage in the
next 20 years or the next hundred years
you know we're running at 40 percent
most of us you know because we're half
in and half out and it's not surprising
because life is difficult it's like well
what if you were 90 in or 95 in or or
all in because you're all in anyways
right it's a it's a life and death game
no one gets out of this everyone dies
you might as well commit yourself and
you might as well commit yourself to the
highest good that you can attain because
why not it'll imbue your life with
meaning it's hard the responsibility is
there but all the meanings in the
responsibility and that'll make your
life better it'll make your family's
life better and should make your culture
better maybe it make the world better
it's like that'll justify your damn
miserable existence at three o'clock in
the morning when you're wondering what
the hell you're doing here and that's a
good thing because there's going to be
days when you're aching and tired and
sore and there's people in your family
that are sick and you're cynical and
bitter and you need a reason to get up
and you think yeah well a little more
heaven and a little less hell maybe I
can pull that off today and tomorrow and
next week and that's worth struggling
forward for my rule too is treat
yourself as if you're someone
responsible for helping and it's sort of
predicated on the idea that regardless
of your inadequacies and your
malevolence which you know I'm sure you
have many inadequacies and no shortage
of malevolence just like everyone else
regardless of that you have a moral
obligation so that would be a
responsibility to assume that despite
all evidence that there's actually
something of intrinsic worth about you
and that as a consequence your duty
bound to treat yourself like that is
true
and then it turns out that if you do
that
well then your life gets better
and and I don't mean happier exactly
although I would say it gets happier I
mean it gets richer and more meaningful
and deeper and and more worthwhile and
and you become more educated and you
become wiser and and and you treat
yourself with more respect and you're a
better model for other people and you're
a better father or a better sister or a
better mother whatever it happens to be
it's and you're less ridden by that
guilt that's that gnaws at you and shame
that's there otherwise saying you're not
what you could be you're not what you
could be and that's a hell of a voice to
get rid of and it's certainly not one
that's easy to ignore so that's a pretty
good
that that idea that there's something
Divine let's say that resides within you
of ultimate worth
um
even as a philosophical statement or a
psychological statement rather than a
metaphysical statement it seems to be a
precondition for establishing properly
harmonious relationships with yourself
and that's that's man that's worth
thinking about a lot you know that you
have because you think you couldn't
think that in some sense you just own
yourself you know because people do kind
of make that claim especially when
they're trying to justify for example
their right to Suicide that you know
it's it's your life it's your body your
yours to do what you will with and if
that was true well then it would seem to
me that life would be a lot more
straightforward because you would just
tell yourself things that you would
instantly obey and believe so first of
all you'd tell yourself all the things
that you were going to do and then you
just run off and do them which you don't
obviously because it's much more
difficult at that and then you'd also
say well enough of the guilt and the
shame and the negative emotion and the
disillusionment and the vengefulness and
all those things that make life hard
especially the self-recrimination it's
like what the hell do we need that for
and if we're our masters of Our Own
Destiny and owners of our own faith then
why can't we just command to ourselves
that that be dispensed with and like
that doesn't work I've never seen
anybody able to do that so I mean you
can fool yourself for very brief periods
of time into thinking that that might
work but
but it doesn't work and and that's
strange and this is one of the reasons I
love the psychoanalysts say because they
were really the people apart from the
religious types who figured out that
whatever you are
you're not a unitary Spirit that's under
your own dominion you know you're
something like a loose Unity of a
multiplicity of spirits many of which
are doing their own thing which you're
striving to bring into some form of
unity but even that Unity isn't
something that's under your control in
any real sense it's it's a Unity that
has its own nature that you have to
exist in relationship to and I would
also say that that's one of the things
that keeps people people's feet firmly
on the ground because otherwise you it's
easy to become egotistical and
narcissistic you know if you if you
think that you're the center of your own
being you know in some fundamental sense
then you're only what you're only
beholden to yourself you're sort of a
self-created creature perhaps you could
think about it that way but it doesn't
work like that it's like the ideal that
constitutes the unity that you might
become then sort of manifests itself for
something that you could strive toward
but aren't and it it also serves as a
judge it's the thing that keeps you up
at night saying you know there's some
things you're just not attending to and
you should get at it because life is
short and there's no shortage of trouble
that you might end up in and a wise
person would attend to the dictates of
his conscience and and lay out his
actions in the world according to what
he knows to be true and correct and
that is how people think and it isn't
obvious that we why we think that way
that this is part of the reason that it
seems to me so obvious that we have a
religious Instinct because I can't think
of what else you would possibly call
that other than a religious Instinct the
notion that our morality is linked to
our desire to survive is I'm perfectly
fine with that
the devil's in the details to some
degree
I mean one of the
fields of endeavor that I've been
particularly struck by is uh
the work of people like Franz DeWall
and friends the wall has written a
serious and also Jacques penkship hey
I'll tell you something cool about rats
some of you I'd like to do that
some of you have probably heard this
before but this affective neuroscientist
named jacquesab he studied rats for a
long time and he's very sophisticated
researcher and I think he was one of the
greatest neuroscientists who lived in
the last 50 years sorry I don't think
there's really any question of that he
might have been one of the top three
might have been
he'd be in the top three be a tight race
up at the top three
he did this great experiment it was so
smart
so
juvenile routes like to play
and they like to wrestle they like to
engage in rough and tumble play and you
might say well how do you know a rat
likes to do something it's like are you
anthropomorphize it and the first thing
I would say to that is you should
anthropomorphize unless there's evidence
to the contrary because we share a
biological platform with rats and
they're a lot like us and a rat is a lot
more like you than your stupid model of
a human being is like a human being
so you try building a rat
hard
so anyways you can tell rats want to
play because if you put them in a little
Arena where they can Rough and Tumble
play and wrestle and then you bring them
there the next time and you make them
work to open the door to play they'll
work and so that's how we know you like
something you'll work for it you know so
you can apply that to rats and they'll
work hard for it and rats deprived of
play their prefrontal cortexes don't
mature and they they're kind of
hyperactive which might tell us
something about boys in school but we
won't go into that
if you take a rat
of the same age as another rat and you
put them in a play area
but the other rat has a 10 weight
advantage
the big rat will pin the little rat and
they actually pin each other pretty much
like dogs do when they're wrestling well
they don't pin quite as much but humans
certainly do it and pin means dominate
dominance or that's one interpretation
you only make that interpretation if you
think that the hierarchies that rats
live in are dominance hierarchies
predicated on the expression of power
and we all kind of think that because we
use the term dominance hierarchy but you
know that's a political term as well as
a scientific term and it's predicated on
the notion that the fundamental basis of
hierarchical structure among mammals and
other complex organisms is power and
that's wrong
it's not just wrong it's it's
corrosively wrong it's misleadingly
wrong it's like it's seriously and not
acceptably wrong anyways you pair the
rats once and you think hey big rat wins
over little rat establishes dominance
That's the basis of the relationship
but the thing about rats is like people
they don't just play once because they
live in social groups that are
reciprocal they play repeatedly and
Banks up being a very smart researcher
realized this so he paired rats
to play the same routes over multiple
occasions
and the first thing he observed was the
second time the rats got together the
little rat had to invite the big rat to
play
you know when rats do the same sort of
thing that dogs do when they want to
play and and that that play behavior is
so cross-species common that all of you
know when your dog wants to play you
know you can you can take your dog and
whack him like that if you do it right
and he goes and tries to bite you but
not really right he plays in his Tails
wagging and and when dogs are playing it
kind of looks like dominance Behavior
like it does among boys because boys
really like to rough and humble play by
the way although girls like it too but
not as much
you can distinguish the play behavior
from aggression and if you can't that
means you never had any friends I mean
no I mean that that's that I mean that
that's what it means it means that's
what it means because part of being able
to have friends is be to be able to
identify aggression versus play and and
part of playing is to pretend to be
aggressive quite aggressively but still
be playing right there's a tremendous
social skill in that anyways
the little rat has to ask the big rat to
play which I imagine is somewhat you
know humiliating for the little rat but
he's the little rat so tough luck for
him and the big rat contained to play
and then they play and then you can
observe how they play over repeated
boats
if the big rat doesn't let the little
rat win at least 30 percent of the time
even though he could win 100 of the time
the little rat will no longer invite him
to play and you think
yeah it's like no not yeah
like the emergence of morality in rats
through play that's a big Discovery man
that's a big Discovery and that's
there's that reciprocity eh that that
exists within the rat hierarchy and
stable hierarchies in complex mammals
are not predicated on power
so friends the wall is showed quite
clearly that you know that so chimps
have a pretty rough hierarchy and it's
pretty male dominated now barnables are
quite different we won't talk about them
because it's not germane to this
particular point but you might think you
know
the biggest chimpanzee with the biggest
teeth
he's the Tyrant he's the winner
and that happens sometimes there are
tyrannical chimpanzee societies but what
dewal has shown quite clearly is that
I don't care how big and tough you are
if you don't play fair
two guys 90 your size can get together
one day when you're not feeling so well
and tear you into bits
and that's exactly what happens among
the Champs
so tyranny you know that can be a route
to dominance it can even be a route to
sexual access because it is the case
among chimpanzees that males who are
higher in the power hierarchy are more
likely to farther Offspring not because
the female chimps choose them because
female chimps aren't choosy unlike human
females it's a profound difference
between the two species but because the
big that more uh superordinate male
chimps chase the soup subordinates away
so but the wall is shown quite clearly
that
the males who managed to occupy
positions of authority
and competence longest in chimpanzee
hierarchies are intensely reciprocal
with the other males more so than the
other chimps in the hierarchy they do a
lot of mutual grooming and are
preferentially attentive to the females
and their infants
and so even among chimps and chimps can
be damn brutal right Jane Goodall
discovered I think it was 1975 another
landmark in in late 20th century
scientists at science that
and this was a real blow to to the
social
constructionist utopians
juvenile chimps Patrol the borders of
their territory and if they come across
chimps from other troops and outnumber
them they will tear them into bits and
chimps are unbelievably strong and it's
unbelievably brutal and so good all
basically discovered that chimps have
the human equip or the the equivalent of
human tribal Warfare
and that's quite frightening if you're
sensible because you know you might be
the kind of optimist who thinks that
human conflict is caused by capitalism
or some bloody Daft notion like that and
that wouldn't that be lovely because
then it would be you could just get rid
of it by getting rid of capitalism which
you wouldn't be able to do anyways but
you know what I mean it's but if it's
I mean we split from chimps about seven
million years ago and
if the problem of Intergroup aggression
is that deep
it's a terrible problem you never want
to underestimate
the people that you're at war with
that's a big mistake
they're and I see no evidence at all for
a clinical Psychopathology on Putin's
side and he's
[Music]
Russians are complicated and he's
complicated he is by no means the worst
leader that brush has had in the last
hundred years not by any stretch of the
imagination I'm not standing up for
Putin but I'm not going to casually
demonize him
you can't take your simplistic
understanding of Adolf Hitler or Joseph
Stalin which is incomplete and then say
well that's Putin it's like look we're
in trouble here
Wars tend to spread and everyone thought
when the first world war started yeah
I'd be a few months and then when it
wasn't they thought well we'll win
easily it's like no that isn't what's
going to happen and the people thought
the same thing in World War II and they
thought the same thing in Afghanistan
and so
this is a localized Ukraine Russia
conflict well first of all no it's not
it's a war by proxy of Russia against
the entire West obviously now all the
world isn't on board with that but much
of the world is but not all of it and so
you know you might say when your sleeve
gets caught in an industrial machine and
only an inch of your sleeve is in you
think well I've still got my whole arm
it's like yeah for the next 10 minutes
but don't be thinking that that's how
it's going to be in half an hour and
it'll be an absolute bloody miracle if
this doesn't engulf us all
and there's a high probability of that
with all of that all that that entails
what would it mean for the Russians to
lose
like let's say that's what the West
wants we want Russia to lose okay well
what do you mean by that lose exactly do
you want the Russians to feel
that they're going to lose they have
atom bombs
what is going to happen to a country
that's already paranoid and misguided
if they also think they're going to lose
you think they're just going to lose and
we're not going to lose along with them
that's not going to happen
and so
we're playing with fire on and I think
I'm I've written an article
uh called the Civil War in the west
because I think what's happening in
Russia and Ukraine is
a civil war in the west it's just that's
just where it started
Russia's the West
and it's not just about post-soviet
territorial expansion it's not just
about oil and gas it's definitely about
those things but it's about way more
it's about the stunning blindness and
stupidity of Europe on the energy front
who didn't know this was going to happen
do you who's so blind that they believed
that making Europe dependent on Russian
oil and gas for environmental reasons
wasn't going to produce this
well we didn't know well if you were a
Statesman and you didn't know that you
are so incompetent that it defies
comprehension because that's so
self-evident how do you frame that how
do you take that emergent chaos and make
habitable order out of it you don't know
is the whole capitalist system rotten to
the core I mean that's a convenient
explanation under those circumstances
that's for sure were you working for a
psychopathic son of a [ __ ] did you make
the wrong choice in University and was
that your father's fault because you
never did what you want or was it your
fault for not standing up to him or is
it a dying industry or is maybe this a
wake-up call that you should go do
something else that you've been waiting
to do you know that you've actually
wanted to do your whole life and that's
why you're doing such a miserable job at
your current occupation because you're
bitter and resentful about the fact that
you never did what you want you don't
know it's all of those things at once
and that's very stressful because all of
those things at once is too many things
and that's the re-emergence of chaos
that's the flood
that's the return to the beginning of
the cosmos that's another way that it's
been represented mythologically it's
that you Voyage all the way back to the
beginning of the cosmos when there's
nothing but undifferentiated chaos and
that's what you're confronting and maybe
it's too much for you and often it is I
mean that that can really that can be
traumatizing it can hurt your brain you
know it's just too much for you to Bear
it doesn't matter you're stuck with it
and so how do you respond to that well
some of it is catastrophic negative
emotion you freeze and that's protective
and maybe you don't even want to move
you don't want to bloody well get out of
bed for a week and that's because your
body is reacting as if the bedroom floor
is covered with snakes and the best
thing for you to do is just not move
just freeze not a pleasant situation to
be in because it's your hyper aroused
very very physiologically demanding and
there's zero about it that's productive
except maybe the snakes won't see you
but they've already seen you so that
isn't helping very well so you've got
all this undifferentiated negative
emotion anxiety fear hurt anger guilt
shame emotional pain the whole plethora
of catastrophes and then maybe on the
other side lurking down there is thank
God I'm done with that job I just bloody
well hate it I drag myself off to work
every day and there's a little part of
my soul that's so goddamn happy I
finally got fired that I can hardly
stand it you know and maybe you don't
even admit that to yourself because well
that would mean that all that time you
spent at the job was just some cost
you're deluding yourself the whole time
um it is an interesting thing to
consider though sometimes if you're in
the unpleasant circumstance of having to
fire someone you know sometimes firing
someone is the best thing that can
happen to them which doesn't mean that
you should go out and like enjoy it
although I have met very disagreeable
people who actually enjoyed firing
people and I'll tell you a story about
that at some point because it's quite
interesting but you know sometimes if
someone's just limping along in their
job and doing it as miserably and
wretchedly as they possibly can imagine
the best thing you can do to them for
them is to say you know
you're failing at this and and that
doesn't necessarily mean that you would
have to be failing at absolutely
everything else in the entire world so
maybe you should just accept the damn
failure and go off and try something new
and I mean that's terrifying for people
and I know they hate it and all that but
but
sometimes it's better than the
alternative which is just slow torturous
death
so
here's a funny way of looking at it
so let's say you fall right into that
hole that's underneath any everything
and you've hit an anomaly that you don't
understand you say what's that anomaly
made out of exactly I know that's a
strange way of thinking about it you
know because it's not or you could say
we'll just go along with that it's a
metaphor what's that anomaly made out of
well here's a way of thinking about it's
made out of Spirited matter
and here's why
this is something I learned in part from
Piaget said
well it's made out of matter because of
course that's the world matter and the
world is also what matters and so that's
kind of a nice Duality there but it's
made out of spirit because when you
encounter something anomalous and go
down the rabbit hole when you go into
the underworld it's underneath
everything that you've relied on
you learn things down there so what's
down there is information
and that now it's maybe way more
information than you want but it is
information it's information and what
can what can you do with the information
you can inform yourself with the
information right you can put yourself
in formation with the information that's
helpful too
and so and you think well you you're a
psyche maybe you're not a spirit it
depends on you know whether you're a
materialist or not but at least we can
say that you're a psyche the question is
what's your psyche made of well it's
obviously got a material substrate but
the matter happens to be a raid in a
particular order and that's an
information order and so when you fall
into the underworld that's underneath
everything and you encounter that latent
information then what you can do is
enhance your psyche you can grow your
spirit because what you do is you take
the new information and you incorporate
it that's like eating the Apple that
Adam and Eve ate you incorporate that
and that makes more of you and that's
not a metaphorical or a metaphysical
proposition it's not it's to say nothing
other than well that's what happens when
children learn you say think what
happens Charles 3 has a pretty low
resolution representation of the world
and is a fairly low resolution human
being got all the constituent elements
there but isn't differentiated in any
tremendous manner that's all still to
come in the future and so what does the
child do explore what do they explore
things they don't understand that's
where the information is because you
already understand what you understand
there's no information there you go
where they're where you don't understand
that's where the information is and out
of that information you generate a
higher resolution world and you generate
a higher resolution self and so out of
the combat with the underlying Dragon of
chaos you generate spirit and matter and
that's what you do when you go down into
the underworld
so if it doesn't kill you
or if it doesn't make you wish you were
dead which it probably will but there's
a bunch of you that has to die down
there anyway so maybe that's not such a
bad thing because if you had this
relationship that ended in betrayal then
there's something that's just not
exactly right right there's something
that went and the reason I'm saying that
you think well that's kind of moralistic
it's like actually I don't mind being
moralistic in case you haven't noticed
but
but that's not it's not a fair comment
because you're playing this stupid game
it's like you live with someone
infidelity that's the game right you've
decided the rules with the game comes a
morality the morality are the rules of
the game well then the thing collapses
into infidelity it's like well you
played the game wrong or it was the
wrong game one of those two you it's one
of those two you pick the damn game and
having picked the game you can't all of
a sudden say well no those aren't the
rules it's like yeah yeah if you pick
the game you pick the rules and if you
fail at complying with the rules then
you failed now you could say well I
could pick a different game it's like I
don't care how you solve the problem
you're still stuck with the problem it's
a moral problem fundamentally
and it might take some major league
retooling too
to fix it
so you're at Point a trying to get to
point B that's not working out you hit
an anomaly
you're not getting to point B that's for
sure
your medical school student you write
your mcats which is this test you have
to write to go to medical school you get
25th percentile I don't know who you are
but you're not a pre-med student and
maybe you never were right and that's
the rub man and so who the hell are you
you don't know collapse down here into
this motivational conflict this place of
motivational and emotional uncertainty
and tremendous information right it's a
place of transformation it's the Phoenix
that burns it's the burning part of the
Phoenix that burns it's it's the journey
to the underworld it's the journey to
hell it can really be a journey to hell
because you may find out that the reason
that your partner betrayed you or that
you didn't get your damn promotions
because there is seriously something
wrong with you and you know it and I
don't just mean that you don't know what
you're doing I mean that there's 25
percent of you that is seriously aiming
at things not being good and so you fall
into the underworld and you find out
that oh
God I just got exactly what I was aiming
for or I got exactly what the worst part
of me was aiming for and that worst part
that's something to clean up and that's
not going to be easy because it's got
its hooks in me like something something
ferocious something seriously ferocious
and I've been toying with it for a very
long time and maybe I can't even detach
it anymore and so that's not so fun and
you see people like that in
Psychotherapy very frequently or you see
them wandering around on the streets
like the absolute catastrophic former
shells of themselves you know because
they've hit the underworld and they
ended up in hell and there's no getting
out of it and so those are the people
you tend to give a wide birth to when
you walk down the street pick up your
damn suffering and bear it
and try to be a good person so you don't
make it worse
well that's a truth you know I read a
lot about
the terrible things that people have
done to each other you just cannot even
imagine it
so awful
so you don't want to be someone like
that now do you have a reason to be yes
you have lots of reasons to be God
there's reasons to be resentful about
your existence everyone you know is
going to die you know you too there's
gonna be a fair bit of pain along the
way and lots of it's going to be unfair
it's like yeah no wonder you're
resentful it's like act it out and see
what happens you make everything you're
complaining about infinitely worse
there's this idea that hell is a
bottomless pit and that's because no
matter how bad it is some stupid son of
a [ __ ] like you could figure out a way
to make it a lot worse
so you think well what do you do about
that well you accept it that's what life
is like it's suffering that's what the
religious people have always said life
is suffering yes well who wants to admit
that well just think about it well so
what do you do in the face of that
suffering
try to reduce it
start with yourself what good are you
get yourself together for Christ's sake
so that when your father dies you're not
winding away in a corner and you can
help plan the funeral and you can stand
up solidly so that people can rely on
you that's better don't be a damn victim
of course you're a victim Jesus
obviously
put yourself together
and then maybe if you put yourself
together you know how to do that you
know what's wrong with you if you'll
admit it you know there's a few things
you could like polish up a little bit
that you might even be able to manage in
your insufficient present condition and
so you might shine yourself up a little
bit and then your eyes will be a little
more open than you can shine yourself up
a little bit more and then maybe you
could bring your family together instead
of having them be the hateful spiteful
neurotic infighting bats that you're
like doomed to spend Christmas with
so then you fix yourself up a little bit
kind of humbly because you know God
you're a fixer-upper if there ever was
one and then you got to figure out well
can you figure out how to make peace
with your Idiot Brother and probably not
because he's just as dumb as you so how
the hell are you going to manage that
and so then you've maybe you get
somewhere that way and your family's
sort of functioning and you find out
well that kind of relieved a little bit
of suffering although it reduced the
opportunities for spiteful revenge and
that's kind of a pain in the neck and so
then you get your family together a
little bit and you're a little clued in
then at least a bit because you've done
something difficult that's actually
difficult you're wiser and so then maybe
you could put a tentative finger out
beyond the family and try to change some
little thing without wrecking it it's
like our society is complex and we teach
our students that they could just fix it
it's like go fix a military helicopter
and see how far you get with that it's
like you're going to do you're like a
chimp with a wrench whack oh look it's
better it's like no it's not better
things are complicated and to fix things
is really hard and you have to be like a
golden tool to fix things and you're not
so and that's the other message of the
West
it's like how do you overcome the
suffering of the of life
and I'm not saying it's only the message
of the West
how do you overcome the suffering of
life is be a better person
that's how you do it well that's hard
it takes responsibility and I think you
know if you said to someone you want to
have a meaningful life
to everything you do matters that's the
definition of a meaningful life but
everything you do matters
you're gonna have to carry that with you
or do you want to just forget about the
whole meaning thing and
then you don't have any responsibility
because who the hell cares and you can
wander through life doing whatever you
want gratifying impulsive desires for
how useful that's going to be and you're
stuck in meaninglessness but you don't
have any responsibility which one do you
want
well ask yourself which one are you
pursuing and you'll find very rapidly
that it isn't the majority of your soul
that's pursuing the whole meaning thing
because well look what you have to do to
do that you have to take on the fact
that life is suffering you have to put
yourself together in the face of that
well that's hard Christ it's amazing
people can even do it I stopped wasting
time
that helped a lot I stopped drinking
I stopped going to bars I really didn't
spend a lot of time with my friends when
I had young kids in particular I had
friends and I I saw them you know with
some degree of regularity but where I
cut Corners was more with social life
outside my family so I spent a lot of
time with my wife and I spent a lot of
time with my kids and I spent a lot of
time on my career and so you have to
make choices and I think those were
reasonable choices I'm not displeased
with them don't abandon your friendships
but
um but you can certainly look at where
you're wasting time and just stop doing
things that you know would be a waste of
time so and I did and so I had enough
room for my marriage and I had enough
room for my kids and I had enough room
for my career and you know sort of a
multi-dimensional career and I was
always a challenge to me too to see how
efficient I could get
um and you could also
and I've really recommended this for
relatively higher income dual income
couples who are trying to pursue dual
careers kids in marriage you can
Outsource you know higher hire a
cleaning lady if you can afford it
um
buy restaurant food if you can afford it
Etc no you can Outsource get you can
have someone do your laundry then you
can concentrate on your marriage and
your kids I know that that you know is
only an Avenue available to people who
have relatively High incomes but people
who have dual incomes have relatively
High incomes and so Outsource what's
unnecessary so that you can concentrate
on what's necessary I mean I didn't do
that when I was beginning my career
because when I lived in the United
States when I was in my late 20s and
starting my family we had one income
you'd think a Harvard beginning
Professor makes a lot of money and I
suppose that's true in some absolute
sense but relatively speaking you know
we didn't have enough money to buy
magazines we we all our money went for
for housing costs and and the basic
necessities of living I had a car that
was 20 years old 25 years old I think it
was old it was bloody thing the doors
fell apart on the person I sold it to
you know like six months down the road
they knew it was a wreck at that point
but we drove that thing right into the
ground so I know that's not necessarily
possible for everyone at the beginning
of their career but if you have two
incomes you can manage it
um
I
concentrated on my marriage and making
time for it I concentrated on spending
time with my kids consciously and I
concentrated on developing my career
those were the three elements of my life
and I had some time left over for
Creative Pursuits and and and for
friends but most of it was a matter of
getting rid of
time wastes of any sort you know and I
just
push that out of my life you know day
after day until I wasn't wasting any
time
or virtually no time and you know I've
asked my undergraduates frequently how
much time they waste per day and general
estimates are like six to eight hours of
time they regard themselves as wasting
like that's a whole career right there
right so if you just stop wasting time
you can do a tremendous amount
especially if you also try to maximize
efficiency and I always found that
incredibly
motivating you know I'm motivating
game how much can I do in the least
amount of time possible that was that's
fun to try to do that as far as I'm
concerned I know me you know that's
maybe it's undoubtedly a temperamental
thing but
but if you're built if you're wired that
way that's a great
meta strategy become efficient I always
ask my graduate students when they were
designing experiments they'd come with a
proposal I'd say to them you know is
there any way you could do this ten
times faster what would you have to cut
what would you have to change to do this
10 times faster
and you can learn to do that I also
learned to
Force the task to fit the time you know
there's this dictum work expands to fill
the time allowed for its completion work
expands to fill the time allowed for its
completion well there's a corollary to
that which is
work
becomes more efficient in proportion to
the restrictions of time placed upon it
so if you say well this could take me
two weeks but I'm going to do the best
job I could in one day you'll be amazed
you can get 90 percent of the way or 95
percent of the way or sometimes even
farther in that day
so that's another way of becoming
efficient you know if you only have 10
minutes to do something that should
maybe take you two hours maybe you can
figure out how to do it in 10 minutes
you can get dreadfully efficient
so that's very much worthwhile in my
estimation if you want to do a lot of
things what what else are you going to
do
you know rather than become efficient if
you want to do many things you don't
have much choice but it I found it
extremely entertaining to try to do that
and when I was healthy
I could do a tremendous amount in a very
short period of time I'm very frustrated
that that's not so much the case now
although perhaps it's coming back to
some degree you know there's a gospel
saying which is of course impossible to
comprehend or believe knock and the door
will open asking you will receive seek
and you will find and people think well
no way the world's not constituted like
that it's like it goes back to the idea
of aim
if you don't aim at it you're not going
to hit it and you know it might also go
back to a question about what do you
mean by ask and what do you mean by want
because it isn't just some casual
request you know you're praying to God I
wish you know I wish I could find my
wallet or something like that as if he's
the Casual grantor of Magical Wishes
like like the like a fairy with a magic
wand you know it's not that asking means
asking means something like this I am
willing to give up everything
that I'm doing wrong
so that I can put things right if I
could know what right was and that's a
non you're on your knees when you say
that man and maybe if you're on your
knees you get the answer
and so that's worth thinking about so
you know if you knocked and you wanted
to walk through and you asked and you
wanted to learn
you know and you saw it because you
wanted to find maybe you would
receive and
be answered and
find
but not without aim if you don't have
some notion of the Divine then you'll
believe any damn thing yeah yeah right I
think that's right and that's what the
kids are doing yeah well I mean
dostoevsky's comment on that was if
there's no God everything is permitted
you know and he did a lovely job of
analyzing that in well in crime and
punishment and the brothers karamazov
and I think it's true I think you'll if
you believe nothing you'll fall for
anything and I really do believe that's
the case and you know you might say well
what what do you mean
you mentioned earlier that people like
to ask me if I believe in God and I
always think well
who are you to be asking that question
first of all you have some notion of
what you mean by believe that you think
is just accurate because you know what
believe means and so you have a a priori
theory about belief and now you're
asking me if my belief in God fits into
your a priority Theory it's how about we
start by questioning your a priority
theory of belief because I don't even
know what you mean by believe and
neither do you especially when we're
asking a question not
profound because it you know
do you believe in God there's two
Mysteries there well three you believe
God all three of those are subject to
um
question
I think people act out what they believe
and so when people ask me if I believe
in God I say generally that I act as if
God exists or I try to act as if God
exists and they're not very happy about
that because they want me to abide by
the rules of the implicit rules of their
question which is no
do you believe in the religious view as
a pseudo-scientific description of the
structure of reality it's like well
I don't even know how to answer that
question because it's so badly
formulated I can't get a handle on it
um
do you believe that there's something
divine
well let's try to Define divine here we
can do that for for a moment most of us
have some sense that literary stories
differ in their depth that's that I
don't think that's an unwarranted
proposition some stories are shallow and
some stories are deep some stories are
ephemeral in some move you deeply
whatever that means it's a metaphor but
we understand what it means
imagine there are layers of literary
depth and one way of conceptualizing the
layers of literary depth is that the
deeper an idea is the more idea other
ideas depend on it
right and so you have fundamental ideas
that are fundamental because if you
shake that idea you shake all the ideas
that are dependent on them and then I
would say well the realm of the Divine
is the realm of the most fundamental
ideas and you don't get to believe in
that or not because the alternative is
to say well all ideas are equal in value
it's like okay well try acting then
and you can't because you can't act
unless you prioritize your beliefs and
if you prioritize them you arrange them
into a hierarchy and if you arrange them
into a hierarchy you accept the notion
of depth
and so that's a no-go
when we use language of the Divine we're
talking about the deepest ideas
and so I believe that
the notion that each individual
is characterized by a Consciousness that
transforms The Horizon of the future
into the present that's a Divine idea
it's so deep and our cultures
necessarily I think functional cultures
are necessarily predicated on that idea
so I don't just think it's a western
idea I don't think you can have a
functional culture that in some sense
doesn't instantiate that idea because
you interfere with the mechanism of
adaptation Itself by not allowing it
free expression
you know and you can be like my prime
minister and you can say well I really
admire the Chinese Communist party
because when it comes to environmental
issues they get things done and I think
I I couldn't begin to tell you how many
things are wrong with that statement
that would take like 15 years to tell
you why your uh an inexcusably
narcissistic idiot but we can start like
simply if you know what you're doing and
you have power if you know what you're
doing maybe you can be more efficient
in your exercise of in your control over
movement towards that goal let's just
assume for a minute that you do know
what you're doing well maybe if you have
power then you're efficient fair enough
man
what about when you don't know what
you're doing
how about then where do you turn because
what that means is your ideology failed
you and do you have a mechanism for
for operating when you don't know what
you're doing well no because we always
know what we're doing because we're
totalitarian and we have a complete
theory of everything and don't say
anything to the contrary or else we've
got it all wrapped up yeah except when
you don't
and so what do we do in free societies
when we don't know what we're doing well
we let people talk and out of that
Babble out of that noise and American
culture is particularly remarkable in
this regard you have this immense
diversity of opinions most of which are
completely useless and some of which are
absolutely Redemptive and one of the
things that's so remarkable as a
Canadian observing your culture in
particular is that you know you guys
Veer off in weird directions fairly
frequently and things look pretty
unstable and then there's some glimmer
of hope somewhere that bursts forward in
in a whole new mode of adaptation and
Away you go again and that just happens
over and over and over and that's a
consequence of real diversity of real
diversity and it's definitely a
consequence of like freedom of
Association and freedom of speech
because it enables all that you're at a
crossroads right here entering a new
phase of your life you can
you're someone different than you were
four years ago
and hopefully someone better
likely someone better
and you have another opportunity now to
be the next iteration of yourself
that you can be
at a Crossroads you know
the metaphor works because you make a
decision you go One Direction or another
and there's an old blues idea that you
meet the devil at the crossroads I
always wondered why that was I thought
it through it's a really compelling
idea you know it's a it's an image that
has a good narrative fit and it sticks
in your memory once you hear it why do
you meet the devil at the crossroads at
midnight maybe that's when you let
examine your conscience
or it examines you
and then you might ask well why do you
meet the devil at the crossroads
and the answer is most fundamentally
because
when you come to a place in your life
where you have to make a choice
and I think this is actually true of
every choice we ever make but it's more
evident when the choice is more
weighty let's say
as the choices that lay themselves out
now in front of you are waiting you aim
up or down
and there is always an agent of
Temptation at every choice Point
enticing you
to aim down
and I thought a lot about what aiming
down means and so all
run through that for a bit the spirit of
Temptation manifests itself for example
in the story of Cain and Abel and so
Cain Falls prey to Temptation and God
bluntly informs him
when he complains about his fate that
the Temptation was freely Chosen and
that he could have done differently and
better and Cain becomes this is in the
aftermath of the improper
sacrifices that he makes
the sacrifices that he makes that are
not everything they could be
they're not in the service of the
highest good
that are deceptive and arrogant
simultaneously because when we make
improper sacrifices we believe in the
deepest part of ourselves that we've
pulled one over God
and Isis suggests that that's a
Temptation you might want to avoid that
presumption
and then you might say well
if you're tempted to aim down
you're tempted to make improper
sacrifices you're tempted to arrogantly
presume that you are going to get away
from it with it that you're not going to
be called on it
what are the pathways down that might
manifest themselves in front of you and
I think the the two stories that follow
the story of Cain and Abel
detail that
so after Cain and Abel Comes The Flood
and that's no accident The Narrative
placement of those stories is definitely
no accidents it's unbelievably
sophisticated from a literary
perspective a philosophical perspective
theological perspective
existential perspective one form of
Temptation is
the nihilistic chaos that's symbolically
represented by the flood right it's the
proliferation of sins
and sin is a word
both its Greek and its Hebrew derivation
are related to archery so the Greek
derivation I hope I haven't got this
wrong because I know there are Greek
scholars in this audience so um the the
word is derived from the Greek word
hamartia which means to miss the mark
and it's an archery term it's lovely I
it's a lovely notion to know that
because to sin therefore means to miss
the target which implies that it has
something to do with aim or the lack
thereof I love that I think it's so apt
and the derivation of the word sin from
the Hebrew Source actually relies on the
same imagery and so to sin is to aim
wrong or to miss the mark and there's a
variety of ways you can miss the mark
right don't aim at all that's a good one
assume there is no such thing as aim
assume all aims are equal
well you sin you missed the mark what
can happen well one way is you can
descent into a kind of nihilistic
hopelessness and that's not you can
understand that you know you meet people
in life whose lives have been so hard
you know you hear their stories they've
suffered so much and they're bitter and
they're hurt and they're resentful and
you think oh my God it's no wonder
you're bitter and hurt resentful I mean
look what you've gone through and but
you also notice that their bitterness
and their resentment and their
hopelessness and their chaos and their
anxiety it's not helping
right it's worsening the problem it's
not making it better and I'm not saying
that people can always resist that
but I I have certainly seen that it's
not helpful but I've also met other
people you know who have had stories
equally catastrophic sometimes more
catastrophic sometimes so catastrophic
you can't even believe that they
survived who are not embittered or made
residential by those experiences and who
continue to aim up and so that makes a
mockery of the of the of a kind of
casual determinism right is that you end
up chaotic nihilistic hopeless anxious
Etc
merely as a consequence of the
unbearable tragedy of your life because
if that was the case then everyone who
had a series of unbearable tragedies
which by the way will be almost all of
us in one way or another at one time or
another would end up
in that catastrophic chaos that that
once
that if manifested broadly enough in a
society produces a flood of
that ends everything and that's well
that's the story of Noah in large part
and Noah you know he's wise in his
Generations was a lovely phrase because
it means for his time and place he was a
good man and that's that's a lens
through which history might well be
viewed you know we're very presumptuous
as moderns we look back and we think
well you know this person who did all
these remarkable things said these
things that we now regard as
inappropriate and therefore can be
dispensed with it's like well what makes
you think that you're above that
criticism 100 years from now that you
know the best you can do is to be as
good as you can in your time and place
and if you can manage that well good for
you if you can transcend that well then
maybe you're some sort of Saint and
you're probably not so aiming at just
the first is not such a bad upper aim if
I've got a friend in my life or a you
know partner that I want to encourage to
come out of that place of Despair into a
better place how do I effectively do
that without overpowering them or
stifling them or making them feel
inadequate which is sometimes the
consequence of trying to change someone
you love well
example is good
but then I would say disabuse yourself
of the notion that you know what is best
for this person you don't not only do
you not know you actually don't want
that responsibility for two reasons
let's say they do what you say
and something good happens to them
well whose Victory is that
yours are theirs and if it's yours did
you just steal it
and then let's say they fail
following your advice well they pay the
price for that and you can skip away
merrily and say well I should have spoke
more carefully it's like you don't mess
about with people's Destiny you do not
know where they're headed now having
said that
you do what you're doing in this
interview in this podcast
you ask people questions
real questions you know like how are you
feeling
I'm not doing so good today well you
know what's up what's going on
and you can't think well I'm going to
ask questions to lead this person in a
particular direction because that's the
same game the same instrumental game you
have to see
what it is that you want to know because
I see this when people ask me questions
after my lectures you know now now and
then or during a q a now and then people
get up and they'll ask a real question
it's part of the ongoing dialogue
something struck them they stand up
there's something they really want to
know so honest question and that goes
real well but
not infrequently someone stands up with
a little prepared speech that's packaged
as a question so I get this from
Christian traditionalists fairly
frequently they get up and they ask me
about my religious convictions but
really what they want to do is Corner me
into admitting that I should accept
Jesus Christ as my savior and and join a
particular let's say uh
um denomination it's not a question
it's just a manipulation
and so your questions like your
statements your question should be
honest and if you ask people questions
and you really listen they will untangle
themselves
and that's partly why people love to be
attended to you know like
if I meet people on the street you know
I ask them their name they're all
usually flustered when they come up to
me they don't really want to interrupt
me and then they're flustered and the
first thing I do is shake their hand and
ask them their name and I listen you
know not that good at remembering names
but I listen to it and and they know how
to say their name and so it kind of
settles them down and then it sort of
marks them out as a person against the
background eh and then if I pay
attention to them and listen they will
tell me something in like 10 seconds
that I need to know
because they are they have something to
say you know
and then if you listen people tell you
what they have to say and then you get
wise because you collect all that
and so you want to help someone
well first of all you would decide that
you're aiming towards help right
and and that you do that in the spirit
of ignorance this is what every good
clinician learns is I don't know where
you're headed I don't know what's wrong
with you this is a hard problem man it's
like what's your problem
I don't know what your problem is
so let's find that out first and then
let's find out
one thing you can ask people this is
actually useful in an argument with
someone you love they're they're upset
with you
what are your preconditions for
satisfaction
now I wouldn't state it like that it's
like
if I could give you what you wanted
right now in the context of this
argument and I wasn't doing it in a
manipulative way what is it that I would
have to say or do that would in
principle satisfy you
and that's a hard question you know and
the person might say well I think you
should apologize and about this and you
know and then I will say
what words should I use and they'll say
well if you loved me you'd know and I
would say no I'm stupid and ignorant and
I don't know what the right words are to
satisfy you so why don't you give me a
hand with that and I'll utter them
inelegantly and awkwardly in a good
faith demonstration of my commitment to
peace and that won't be so good because
maybe it would have been better if I
came up with it myself but maybe next
time I can do slightly better
and that works it it requires the person
who's after you to think through
the question even of whether there's
anything that could be said or done that
would satisfy them and if the answer to
that is no well probably the
relationship is over but certainly
the person that they're accusing has
been put in an absolutely impossible
position
but usually almost inevitably
if the person meditates on it for a bit
there is something that would satisfy
them that can be negotiated as long as
they're willing to give you the
opportunity to do it you know stupidly
and badly
so listening man
there's Jimmy Carr I talked to Jimmy
Carr two weeks ago this comedian yeah it
was real interesting
um he said comedy is the most dialogical
of
of the entertainment forms and I thought
well what do you mean by that because
you're just it's a monologue right now I
do monologues but I pay attention to the
audience right I'm always talking to
individual people in the audience and
watching their reactions and listening
to the audience as a whole so even
though it's a lecture let's say or a
talk
I'm watching the audience and responding
so we're in a kind of dance well Carr
pointed out that comedians before they
hit the road and this is virtually in
invariably the case
they have their new routines so they're
they're Corpus of potentially funny
jokes and then they do 200 shows in
front of small audiences and
the audience either laughs or doesn't
and if you're listening you collect all
the jokes that people laugh at if you do
that 200 times you have nothing but
hilarious material but you listened and
then you can go out on the road and that
was very interesting to me because humor
is a mysterious
phenomenon but experientially and
conceptually and it's sort of
precognitive and instinctual but it's
also extremely sophisticated then
there's an element of transcendence
about it right because you can laugh at
yourself and that's in some sense the
highest form of humor
and so it's so interesting that we can
criticize and Elevate ourselves at the
same time and that we find that
intensely pleasurable
and so a good comedian collects ways to
do that shares them with the audience
and he's listening and so if you want to
help someone
the best way to help someone is not to
give them advice
but to listen to them it's a mistake to
be fatally cynical about politics
because
for all the reasons there are to be
fatally cynical about politics there's
much more reason to be fatally cynical
about the conflict that will inevitably
arise or the Tyranny that will
inevitably manifest itself if we can't
handle the dirty business of politics
properly
so I would say don't become prematurely
cynical about it the next thing I would
say is
what do you know
and that's a very important question
it's like
what does it mean to get into politics
exactly
does that mean to seek political power
does that mean to seek power
well first of all you shouldn't be
seeking power you should be seeking
competence
and in order to seek competence you
better know something and so I would say
well if you want to get into politics
you want to educate yourself you know in
all the things you need to be educated
in life I mean you can you can start to
play the political game to familiarize
yourself with it but you know it's not
such a bad idea to well it's not such a
bad idea to have a job for a while and
and maybe a career and maybe it's not
such a bad idea to have a successful
career upon in which people are
dependent on you so that you start to
understand what that sort of
responsibility means and then maybe it's
not such a bad idea to have a family
because like human beings mature adult
human beings tend to have families and
and they transform when they have
families because when you have children
then someone becomes more important to
you than you are and you're not mature
until that happens and so that's
necessary and so I would say well make
sure that if you're looking to get into
politics that you're even more looking
to get into competence and that you
learn everything you can possibly learn
that would make you a reasonably wise
person by the time you attain whatever
level of power you might Authority let's
say you might be seeking I mean I've
seen lots of people get into politics
you know this happens with ideologues
and the way they ratchet themselves up
the power hierarchy is by being more
effective avatars puppets of their
particular ideological stance and
there's nothing about that that's useful
there's nothing in it that will solve
any real world problems and there's
plenty that will make it much worse and
so if that's what getting into politics
means I would say stay the hell away
from it but if it's a matter of
developing your character and then at
some point adopting your social
responsibility then go for it and more
power to you because we need people who
are competent and careful and truthful
and courageous and forthright to enter
the political sphere so that things
don't degenerate and hopefully have some
ounce of at least maintaining themselves
or improving
so
there's you need what do you need to
know you you need to be really good at
at least one thing you have to
specialize you have to be a great
networker you have to know a lot of
people you have to be honest you have to
be articulate you have to you have to
have a vision you have to have a
strategy you have to know something
about history and economics and politics
be good to know something about science
you know you have to be a polymath of
sorts before you should dare to enter
that realm with any degree of confidence
because otherwise all you are is a Loose
Cannon and you'll come up with global
proposals to improve improve the world
you know by waving your wand that will
do nothing but make everything worse I
want to tell you a little bit about how
to conceptualize Free Will I think first
because it's obvious that we don't have
infinite free will our our choice our
choices are constrained in all sorts of
ways and I think part of the reason that
there's a
a continual discussion about Free Will
and the philosophical
in the philosophical literatures because
[Music]
just conceptualizing the issue properly
is extraordinarily difficult so I like
to think about it at least in part the
way that you think about a game you know
if you're playing a game obviously the
game has rules so if it's a chess game
or a basketball game then there are
things that you can do and things that
you can't do
and but and so it's it's a it's a it's a
closed World in some sense but the fact
that there are things you can't do when
you play a game also seem to open up a
universe of possibilities for things
that you can do so chess obviously
constrains you to a board and to a
certain number of men and to a certain
pattern of rules but the strange thing
is is that when you put in those rules
because rules sound like limits they
sound always like things you can't do
but when you set up a constrained world
like that and you lay out a system of
rules what you do is open up an Infinity
of of a near Infinity of possibilities
same with music You Know music has rules
obviously and and if you follow the
rules then you can make an infinite
variety of music and so
and so there's a there's a very
interesting Dynamic that's hard to
understand between constraint and
possibility and there's a deep idea
that's associated with that that I read
in some Jewish commentary on on the
biblical stories that I I read a long
time ago
um talking about the relationship
between God and man and the idea was
that God
imagine it being with the classical
attributes of God omniscience
omnipotence and omnipresence all seeing
all knowing and all-powerful what is it
being like that lack
and obviously the answer is nothing
right because
by definition those three traits
provide for absence of limitation but
then that's exactly what's lacking is
limitation and there's some strange
connection between limitation and and I
was saying say limitation
that that's rule governed as I mentioned
before and the opening up of possibility
so
that isn't necessarily the case that now
determine determinism and limitation
aren't exactly the same thing but
they're analogous and they need to be
discussed together okay so now so that's
the first thing is that our whatever our
free choice is it isn't Limited it's or
it's limited it's it's deeply limited
now here's another thing if I take my
arm and I go like this
see I'll do that again
now you see there's a movement like that
and then my hands stopped just before my
my other hand now it takes a certain
amount of time for the neural messages
to go from my brain to my arm and back
and the time it takes my hand to go like
this and stop is actually shorter than
the time it takes a message to get to my
brain and back so what that means is
that when I
when I plan this movement which is
called a ballistic movement it's called
a ballistic movement because it's like a
bullet once you let it go it's gone
there's no calling it back I've actually
organized the neurological and muscular
sequences that enable that action before
it's implemented I set all that up and
then it's released and the whole thing
Cascades and so
once the action has been released let's
say then I don't really have any free
will because I can't stop it now so so
you think about that it looks like
there's a temporal gradient with regards
to Free Will is that as you look out
into the future maybe perhaps the
farther out you look into the future
um the farther down the road let's say
the more free your choices are but the
closer they get to implementation the
more they become deterministic governed
by standard causal processes and there's
some transition point where they change
from being what we would describe as
choice that we haven't got to free
choice yet but at least to choice
there's some transition point between
that and Ballistic Movement we know
enough about psychology now to know that
almost all of the positive emotion that
you're going to experience in your life
and positive emotion is analgesic by the
way right it actually quells pain so
it's not just positive it also gets rid
of negative which is a big plus almost
all the positive emotion that you're
going to feel you're going to feel in
relationship to a goal because you feel
positive emotion as you approach a goal
and so if you want to feel positive
emotion then you need a goal and then
you might think well if you want to
maximize that positive emotion which is
enthusiasm and also what pulls you out
into the world as well as feeling good
then you need the best possible goal
well that because that's going to engage
them
largest
segments of your being like if your goal
is too narrow then a bunch of you isn't
going to be on board for it you know if
the goal is well developed and
multifaceted then all of you can partake
in that even your negative elements even
your anger and and your fear can get on
board with that let's say so you need a
goal man that's worthy you've got to
think you're good you need a goal that
justifies the tragedy and malevolence of
life that seems to be the bottom line
now maybe you think well there's no gold
that can do that it's like well
there are still better and worse goals
so and I'm not convinced that there are
no goals that can do that I think that's
an open question
you'd never know that until you pursued
the proper goal long enough to find out
who you would be
as a consequence of pursuing it so
that's also your destiny or your
existential Voyage right it's also not
something that anyone else can do for
you someone can say get your act
together for Christ's sake and get it
get get at it that's that'll make the
world unfold best for you but there's no
way you can know that without doing it
so
and unless you think you've done a
particularly Stellar job of that then
you have no reason to doubt its
potential validity
so plus like crickets are telling you
this and so
you know they're a very reliable source
okay so you see the star the star recurs
as a motif in Pinocchio and one of the
more interesting elements of it here is
that when Geppetto wants to transform
his puppet the marionette who's being
played by forces that operate behind the
scenes which is a really good definition
of the Persona from a union perspective
right and also something indicative of
something like an ideological or
conceptual possession
Geppetto who's a good guy he's a
positive father figure
lifts his even though he's a patriarchal
figure right and a very competent one he
still even lifts his eyes up to
something that transcends his motive
being positive as it is and wishes that
his creation would undertake the kind of
transformation that would make it
autonomous and fully functional as a
moral agent no strings right so that's
very interesting I think
said the salvation of mankind lies only
in making everything the concern of all
that's a pretty decent star-like goal I
would say
and so what happens in the Pinocchio
story is that because and I think this
is a symbolic representative of what I
just described to you that happens at a
genetic level if you put yourself in new
situations so
Geppetto is roughly culture in the
Pinocchio story right he's he's a
Craftsman he's he's a and and he makes
Pinocchio so he's he's
who's his son he's the socializing agent
and
he aims for something above mere
socialization which is I think part of
the mysterious element of human beings
you know in our scientific models we
basically have socialization and biology
but there's always a third element
mythological stories which is whatever
you might construe as the spontaneous
action of Consciousness that's
associated with free will and you know
that's just basically being
conceptualized in religious terms as
something akin to the soul now we don't
have a category for that scientifically
because what we try to do scientifically
is to reduce everything either to
socialization or to biology
but it isn't clear to me that that's
it's perfectly reasonable from the
perspective of practicality at a
scientific level you don't want to
multiply explanatory principles Beyond
necessity but there's many things that
that doesn't come to terms with such as
the fact that we all treat each other as
autonomous beings with Free Will and
that that seems to work and that if we
stop doing that then things go to hell
very very rapidly so and the mere fact
that we have been able to conceptualize
what that conscious Free Will might be
metaphysically or physically doesn't
mean it doesn't exist it just means that
we don't understand it I mean but it was
only in the last 15 years that we
discovered that 95 of the universe was
made out of some kind of matter that we
can't even
whose properties we can't even imagine
except that it seems to have mass
so
anyways what happens is when Geppetto
reach lifts his eyes up to the star
he so it's Society aligning itself with
the proper goal with regards to
individual development right so so there
instead of society being at odds with
the individual they line up and then
what happens is nature comes on board
that's the Blue Fairy in the in the
Pinocchio story and that's seems to me
to be a symbolic representation of what
happens biologically when when you set
the goal properly get your culture
behind you and move into the world is
that
there's a biological transformation that
occurs as a consequence of that which
means that a bunch of you that hasn't
been turned on turns on
and I guess one question would be is
what would you be like if you turned on
everything inside of you that could be
turned on
well that's a good goal that's a good
thing to find out
so
now
I'm going to introduce a couple of other
ideas so
there's this idea in jungian Psychology
called the circumambulation and Jung had
this idea that you had a potential
future self which would be in potential
everything that you could be and that it
manifests itself moment to moment in
your present Life by making you
interested in things and the things that
you're interested in are the things that
would guide you along the path that
would lead you to maximal development
now it sounds like a metaphysical idea
or a or a mystical idea even but but
it's not it's it's not it's a really
profoundly biological idea the idea is
something like well
you're set up so that you're
automatically interested in those things
that with fully expand you as a
well-adapted creature well like there's
nothing radical about that idea how well
what else could possibly be the case
unless there's something fundamentally
flawed about you that is what the
situation would be it's kind of
interesting to think about how that
would be manifest moment to moment but
the idea is something like well your
interest is captured by those things
that lead you down the path of
development
well that better be the case Okay so
that's fine and so there's some utility
in pursuing those things that you're
interested in that's the Call to
Adventure let's say
so and the call to adventure takes you
all sorts of places now the problem with
the Call to Adventure is like what the
hell do you know
you might be interested in things that
are kind of warped and bent
and often it's the case that when new
parts of people manifest themselves and
grip their interests say they do it very
badly and shoddily and so you stumble
around like an idiot when you try to do
something new that's why the fool is the
precursor to the Savior from the from
the symbolic perspectives because you
have to be a fool before you can be a
master and if you're not willing to be a
fool then you can't be a master so
so you're gonna it's an error error
written process and that's also laid out
in the Old Testament stories because the
first thing that happens to all these
patriarchal figures when God kicks them
out of their father's house when they're
like 84 is that they they run into all
sorts of trouble and some of it's social
and some of it's natural and some of
it's a consequence of their own moral
inadequacy so they're fools and but but
the thing that's so interesting is that
despite the fact that they're fools
they're still supposed to go on the
adventure and that they're capable of
learning enough as a consequence of
moving forward on the adventure so that
they straighten themselves out across
time
and so it's something like this this
circumambulation that Jung talked about
was this continual we'll return to this
this continual circling in some sense of
who you could be you might notice for
example that there are themes in your
life you know when you go back across
your experiences you see you kind of
have your typical experience that sort
of repeats itself and there might be
variation on it like a musical theme but
it's it's like you're circling yourself
and getting closer to yourself as you
move across time that's the
circumambulation now you remember that
for a sec because we'll go back to it
okay so imagine that something glimmers
before you it's an interest that's
Dawning and you decide well first of all
you're paralyzed you think well how do I
know if I should pursue that it's
probably a stupid idea and the proper
response to that is you're right it
probably is a stupid idea because almost
all all ideas are stupid and so the the
probability that as you move forward on
your adventure that you're going to get
it right the first time is zero you it's
just not going to happen and so then you
might think well maybe I'll just wait
around until I get the right idea and
which people do right so they're like 40
year old 13 year olds which is not a
good idea so they wait around until it's
waiting for Godot until they finally got
it right but the problem is you're too
stupid to know when you've got it right
so waiting around isn't going to help
because even if it the perfect
opportunity manifested itself to you in
your incomplete form the probability
that you would recognize it as the
perfect opportunity is zero you might
even think it's the worst possible idea
that you've ever heard of anywhere
highly likely highly likely so so you
have there's Nitric called that a will
to stupidity which I really liked so
because he thought of stupidity as being
it you know it's it's you have to take
it into account fundamentally and work
with it and so and so you can take these
tentative steps on your pathway to
Destiny and you can assume that you're
going to do it badly and that's really
useful because you don't have to beat
yourself up it's pretty easy to do it
badly
but the thing is it's way better to do
it badly than not to do it at all and
that's the continual message that Echoes
through these historical stories in
Genesis it's like these are flawed
people they they should have got the
hell out of their house way before they
did
um and they go out and they stumble
around in tyranny and famine and
self-betrayal and and
violence and but it's a hell of a lot
better than just rotting away at home
it's not all that happens though when
they eat the fruit of the tree of the
knowledge of Good and Evil because it's
not called the fruit of the tree of the
knowledge of nakedness it's called the
fruit of the tree of the knowledge of
Good and Evil and I thought about that
for a tremendous amount of time it's
like what in the world because I assume
these old stories make sense you know
it's a game I play it's like they're old
they've been around a long time I'm not
sure why they're there but there they
are they're at the basis of our culture
like many many of the stories that we
depend on depend on them our whole
culture grew out of their Roots let's
say and so I assume that our ancestors
who managed to survive conditions that
would have done a lot of us in very
rapidly I can tell you were a lot
smarter than we think and that the
mysterious processes that that produce
these stories and compelled us to
remember them are a lot more
psychologically significant than we
generally tend to presume so I give them
the benefit of the doubt and try to
understand why it is that they might
make sense instead of assuming that they
don't and that that's not easy
has their complicated stories and so I
thought about this nakedness knowledge
of Good and Evil idea for a very very
long time like about 20 years puzzling
it out was what the hell is the
relationship between discovering that
you're naked and discovering good and
evil and then one day mostly because of
studying totalitarianism
totalitarianism and the atrocity the
proclivity for people to commit atrocity
in the service of their group belief or
maybe just because that's what they were
like
clued me in and I thought I see this is
one of the things that really makes
people different than animals it's like
you know it's one thing to realize that
you're naked to realize that you're
naked means that you know that you're
limited in time and space that you're
mortal and that you're you're subject to
degeneration and to social humiliation
and to your own harsh judgment all of
that nakedness to Know That You're
vulnerable against the world and
definitely a source of shame because of
that
um and and a felt lack of
self-sufficiency and no wonder and no
wonder it's understandable but the other
thing is is that this is and this is the
rub it's like
if you're out in a veld and you're not
being very careful and a hungry lion
jumps on you and eats you you don't
really think of the lion as evil I mean
you might write at that moment but you
know philosophically it's not evil it's
just hungry and as soon as it's not
hungry then
goes and has a sleep and it's not up to
some malevolent trick it's it's done for
the day but human being that's a whole
different sort of creature and because
human being is capable of doing terrible
things to someone else and consciously
so think well what's the connection
between that and nakedness itself and it
seems to be this is like here's the
thing is that once I realized that I can
be hurt you know I have a self-conscious
model of my own vulnerability
then I can generalize that to other
people I can think oh this is
interesting here's how I can be heard by
myself here's how I can be hurt by
Society here's how I can be hurt by
nature and by the unknown and what that
implies is that well you can be hurt
with exactly the same mechanisms
and that immediately becomes part of my
what would you say my repertoire of
ability
and then all of a sudden you the world
is no longer
a walled
a Walled Garden and a well-watered place
but it's a moral story because with that
ability to inflict suffering comes the
knowledge of good and evil as far as I'm
concerned those are identical
propositions because now we have the
choice a deep choice about how we're
going to treat ourselves and each other
we can inflict tremendous pain and
suffering on each other in a very
voluntary and and conscious manner in in
a way that no other animal can manage
and that's the dawning of the moral
sense that capacity we now have to
choose to
mitigate or exaggerate suffering and and
that's not all but it's a huge part of
it physical attractiveness is a very
complex trait
um it's also for example it's a marker
of health and of course health is a mar
is a prerequisite for Success so
um I you can't take attractiveness as a
unitary Dimension and measure it
sufficiently accurately
wait I should back up on that
no one that I know of has taken physical
attractiveness as a unitary concept
measured it accurately and then pitted
against IQ and the big five to see if it
to what degree it adds incremental
validity to the prediction of long-term
success but physical but and so I can't
give you a technical answer you know I
can say well in a complex job over the
long run IQ accounts for maybe 20
percent of the variance in success
leaving 80 percent therefore random
events and and the big five traits and
connection networks and and family
background and all those other things
gender perhaps that all the other things
that determine success
we know that physical that people who
are physically attractive though are
given the benefit of Doubt by other
people they they benefit from the
positive halo effect and the positive
halo effect is the propensity of people
to assume good things about someone if
there is one outstanding thing about
them that's easily evident that's good
and so if you're if you're if you stand
up straight with your shoulders back so
that's rule 1 and 12 rules for life then
people are going to see you as more
attractive if you're symmetrical you're
more attractive if you're thin but not
too thin you're more attractive
[Music]
um
well and then there's like good skin and
good teeth and good hair and and all of
those things in proper proportions and
youth and there's a whole slew of things
that that that feed into that if you are
characterized by a plethora of those
features then people are also going to
assume that you're more competent and
more
um and more
more worth having around let's say but
the problem is is that you are
so separating out the attractiveness
from the things the attractiveness are
is correlated with is very hard that's
why you have to do multivariate analysis
that's multi-variable analysis in any
complex social science because a lot of
these traits overlap so but you know you
can you can there's there's some some
things you can do about that postural
adjustment is helpful to work out with
weights that's extraordinarily helpful
that that increases improves your
posture and makes you more confident and
and and and and and and
and you can dress reasonably well and
intelligently and
um all of those things to to help
yourself capitalize on whatever
attractiveness you can muster you need
structure you need predictability and
you need more of it than you think just
to keep you sane now if you're lucky and
and maybe a bit odd you can deviate five
percent from the norm or ten percent
from the norm or something like that
carefully and cautiously as long as the
rest of you is all well ordered in a
normative manner you might be able to
get away with that and you might be able
to sustain it across time and people
might be able to tolerate you if you do
it or maybe you'll get really lucky and
you happen to be creative but reasonably
well put together and people will
actually be happy that there's something
idiosyncratic and unique about you but
even under those circumstances mostly
what you want is to
have a routine that's disciplined it's
predictable and bloody well stick to it
you're going to be way healthier and
happier and saner if you do that and
then the other thing that you need
because this is one of the things the
psychoanalysts got wrong I think is that
they overestimated the degree to which
sanity was a consequence of internal of
being properly structured internally you
know
because from the psychoanalytic point of
view you're sort of an ego and that ego
is inside you and of course it rests on
an unconscious structure but the purpose
of psychoan analysis is to sort out that
unconscious structure and the ego on top
of it and to make you a fully
functioning and autonomous individual
but there's a problem with that because
the reason that you're saying as a fully
functional and autonomous human being
isn't because you've organized your
psyche even though that's important the
reason that you're saying if you're
aware if you have a well-organized
unconscious and ego is because other
people can tolerate having you around
for reasonably extensive periods of time
and will cuff you across the back of the
head every time you do something so
stupid that people will dislike you
permanently if you continue and so what
people are doing to each other all the
time just non-stop is broadcasting
sanity signals back and forth right it's
like you smile at people if they're well
if they're not not only behaving
properly but behaving in a way that you
would like to see them continue to
behave you frown at them if they're not
you ignore them if they're not you shun
them you you roll your eyes at them you
manifest a disgust face you don't listen
to them you interrupt them you won't
cooperate with them you won't compete
with them it's like you're blasting
signals of other people about how to
regulate their behavior so frequently
well it just makes up all of your social
interaction that's why we face each
other and we have emotional displays on
our face and we're looking at each
other's eyes and we know exactly we know
as much as we can about what's going on
with each other given that we don't have
immediate access to the contents of
their Consciousness and so partly what
you're doing with your routine is
establishing yourself as a credible
reliable trustworthy potentially
interesting human being who isn't going
to do anything too erratic at any moment
and everyone else is around there
tapping you into shape making sure that
that's exactly what you are and that's
how you stay sane and so what happens to
people too if they don't have a routine
and they get isolated as they start to
drift and they drift badly because the
world is too complicated for you to keep
it organized all by yourself you just
cannot do it so a lot of our so we
Outsource the problem of sanity
and it's very intelligent that we
Outsource the problem of Sanity because
sanity is an impossibly complex problem
and so the way that we manage the
incredibly complex problem is we have a
very large number of brains working
simultaneously on the problem all the
time it's like a stock market for sanity
and it's partly and I use that I use
that definition with purpose because the
stock market does the same kind of
impossible thing right because it tries
to price things which is impossible
there's how many things are there like a
billion how in the world do you decide
what the price is you can't decide what
the price is that's why you have a stock
market as well in a free market I mean
for for consumer goods is everyone's
voting on what the price of everything
is all the time and that's the way we
figured out because it's actually it's
technically impossible that's partly why
the stock market explodes now and then
and there's Bubbles and all that sort of
thing but anyways the point is
things are chaotic in Alice in
Wonderland when Ellis goes down the
rabbit hole
that's the underworld right
so now she's gone into the substructure
of being
and she meets the red queen and the Red
Queen is Mother Nature
and mother nature is running around
yelling off with their heads off with
her heads
which is of course what Mother Nature
does and she tells Ellis in My Kingdom
you have to run as fast as you can just
to stay in the same place
and that's exactly right and that's a
description of
in fact evolutionary biologists
psychologists have picked up on that
phrase they call it the Red Queen
problem and the Red Queen problem is
everything's after you all the time and
you're not smart enough to do anything
about it or enough about it
and so that's a permanent existential
problem so how do you deal with that
you've got a biological structure
so your embodiment is part of the
solution to the problem and then you're
enculturated
and because you're enculturated
so you're taught a lot of things that
you need to know but mostly what you're
taught is how to communicate with other
people in an acceptable manner and then
once you can communicate with people in
an acceptable manner then you can
Outsource your problems constantly but
you're doing constantly and so we're in
this continual Dynamic exchange of
problem solving so if you're a
socialized person that's what you get
access to and that's something to know
if you're going to have kids and I
mentioned this I think in a previous
lecture
per the purpose of being a parent for
very young children is to make your
children
exceptionally socially desirable by the
age of four because if you can do that
they're set because everyone wants them
around and as soon as everybody wants
them around they want to play with them
they want to cooperate when they want to
compete with them it's like the door is
open the door is open and they stay sane
because they've got all sorts of people
who actually like them that are helping
them out and so that's your goal is to
make them as socially acceptable as you
possibly can socially desirable as you
possibly can and that doesn't mean
you render them obedient without Spirit
right that's that's a tyrants mode of of
enforcing social acceptability it's like
never do anything wrong well that's not
any way to I mean that's a good piece of
advice you know like but
it's missing the other half which is do
a bunch of things that are right so that
so that people are thrilled to have you
around and to and encourage that that's
what you want to do as a parent as well
as inculcating the order and so you know
when in this little diagram I indicated
that there's God the Father with the son
behind him and he's ruling over this
walled City so he's like The Meta Spirit
of the walled City
it's very very nice very nice image
brilliant image so it's is the
collective Spirit of the city that's
another way of thinking about it or the
collective Spirit of the city across
time or the collective Spirit of the
force that built and maintained the city
across time even better and that's
associated with the sun because it's a
it's it's it's associated with
Enlightenment and illumination and all
of those things that we associate with
higher Consciousness and vision it's a
brilliant image and then I overlaid this
you know now of course the the
patriarchal
aspect of existence can become
tyrannical
it does that quite regularly it's one of
the existential dangers of human
civilization is that Civilization is a
medication for chaos but it can spin out
of control in and of itself and become
its own sort of problem which is like a
hyper order problem generally which then
produces a chaos problem so every
solution carries within it certain
problems right because no solution is
perfect and so you have to keep things
in Balance but it's one of the reasons
that I'm really uh
let's call it irritated about the
postmodernists because they keep
yammering about the patriarchy and it's
very very annoying because because it's
self-evident that social structures are
tyrannical it's like that's not news
folks that's obvious but that's not all
they are and it's it's the it's the
reduction of the entire
complex
solution let's say to a uni-dimensional
problem it's just tyranny it's like no
actually it's not just tyranny if you
spent six months somewhere that was just
tyranny you'd know the difference very
very rapidly and that doesn't mean that
everyone doesn't give up a pound or two
or ten or Twenty of Flesh to participate
even in a society that's as free as a
western Society is we all get crushed
and molded by the tyrannical force of
social convention
but at least in principle the benefit is
worth the cost and then it's also up to
you to make sure that you don't
sacrifice more to the group than you
should and you can start to tell if
you're sacrificing more to the group
than you should because you start to
become resentful of other people that's
part of that that's part of the
psychological mechanism that's informing
you of that so it's up to you to fight
against the you know the overarching
pressure for Conformity to retain your
individual logos let's say but that's
sort of your problem it's like the group
wants you to behave
now if you could behave and be
creatively productive so much the better
but that's pretty damn rare so the group
generally tends to settle just for
behave and there's a tyrannical element
of that but what the hell is the
alternative it's you know our society is
based on consensus and the consensus is
based on the sacrifice of a certain
sacrifice of individuality even though
individuality is absolutely necessary as
a revitalizing force for this Society
it's a very tight touch tough thing to
manage properly look when you were
possessed by those ideas you might have
been at least partially authentic
because one of the things you might ask
yourself is well were they Stepping
Stones to a better you you know people
get possessed all the time because they
admire certain ideas and sometimes that
admiration impels them into a kind of
apprenticeship and so they were stupider
before they got possessed by that idea
and as they
trans transformed themselves across the
apprenticeship cycle say being
apprenticed to this fad like idea they
learn something from it so you know you
might you might have learned and grown
as a consequence of what possessed you
now you know it's possible that a lot of
that spoke to the development of parts
of you that
you don't want to develop you know that
they spoke to your malevolence and spoke
to your desire to manipulate and all of
that and you have to sort that out but
look I also don't think it's all that
easy to
figure out when you're authentic that
that's subtle you know you you your felt
sense of confidence in your words when
you're not trying to win is something
like your ability to judge your
authenticity you know are you saying
this to achieve a local Ender are you
saying this because you have thought
deeply and this is the best expression
you can manage of a deeply held
conviction that's a lifetime it's a
lifetime of work or it's a lifetime work
to sort those things out the best I
could come up with was in my first book
well the first of the more popular books
in 12 rules for life
don't lie
now not lying is not the same as being
authentic exactly because
as your question highlights it's not
that easy to tell when you're telling
the truth right because well what the
hell do you know it's certainly not the
truth what you know it might be your
best approximation but it's certainly
not the truth and you're by no means
unerring in your ability to discern when
it is that you're even speaking your
truth because that's so complicated you
just have to practice doing that
continually to get anywhere near good at
it it's it's years and years of effort
to of stringent moral effort to begin to
manage that but I do believe that people
can tell by and large when they're
outright lying and they can stop doing
that they can stop saying things they
know to be false
and so that's
the most obvious impediment to
authenticity is outright lies of
commission stop engaging in those stop
saying things you know to be false now
that begs the questions how do you know
them to be false well
that's complicated sometimes that's a
feeling of repugnance at your own words
sometimes it's a feeling of touchy
embarrassment so that if people call you
in what you say you get
disproportionately angry
um sometimes it's knowing a set of facts
that you haven't let affect the way you
think or present yourself you know
you're purposefully keeping yourself in
the fog as per rule three of Beyond
order
um those are all things you have to sort
out for yourself but I think it starts
with
an Act of Faith
and which is at least in part why
religious systems insist upon faith and
Faith isn't belief in something that no
one's saying would believe you know
that's that's a misapprehension of faith
faith is something like
a decision that
truth serves the good and the good is
worth serving and so therefore truth is
worth serving it's just that's an
axiomatic proposition and you can debate
its empirical justification and of
course we wouldn't be tempted into
temptation if we couldn't debate it's
empirical justification because the
objection is yeah and what exactly does
truth buy you that falsehood wouldn't
buy you better and if you don't think
that you're tempted by that counter
position well then you don't know
anything about Temptation because that
is the temptation of the counter
position so and it's powerful Temptation
that's why it's a statement of faith
that just that that
conquers it
it's a decision
so
you probably were possessed by an idea
but maybe there was something in you
that was striving to be authentic and
maybe you can speed that process of
transformation Along by vowing by taking
a vow and that's adopting a religious
commitment which is I'm going to serve
truth and the good despite the proximal
cost
and that's a statement of faith because
you're staking your life on that
right because every decision you make
from here on in will be a will be
affected by that by that decision so
it's a fundamental decision
and
hopefully that will guide you
in your Endeavor so that your possession
by cultural fads which might be a
necessary part of your apprenticeship
will be temporary and serve this
zigzagging path to something that's
better for you in the future I would say
I mean
we don't understand Consciousness we
don't really understand its place in the
cosmos let's say but I'm not qualified
to answer such questions and I would say
though that no no one stops listening to
a symphony because they know it's going
to end
and so I think in some sense our proper
task is to find the meaning within the
finite when I have clinical clients who
were consumed with such questions
because you know you can pick a time
frame of evaluation that makes all your
efforts futile right well the sun isn't
going to envelop the earth I I think
it's 4 billion years so like get ready
it's like well what's the point of
stopping this baby from crying when the
sun is going to envelop the Earth and
for well yeah you all laugh right but
but that laughter you see that's a sign
of wisdom
you know that's preposterous why
I mean that's the existential question
right it's like well if all if we're all
doomed to ashes and Decay why do
anything well I use the baby crying for
a reason
I mean who in the world is going to use
that argument to not feed their baby
well why feed that thing in four million
years the sun's going to develop the
Earth it's like wrong time frame folks
and so what I would say and I did say to
my clinical clients if if you're
adopting a time frame that makes what
you're doing a pure trivial
the problem isn't necessarily what
you're doing although it might be and
you have to ask yourself that question
because perhaps you are engaging in
something that's more trivial than you
should be the problem is that your mind
which is capable of Leaping across
evaluative Frameworks has picked a time
frame inappropriate for the task so quit
doing that instead you could say well
why don't you practice adopting the time
frame that imbues your properly oriented
action with the deepest possible
apprehended meaning and why would you
not think that the fact that that
meaning manifests itself with the proper
choice of time frame why wouldn't you
accept the fact that's indication of a
valid Choice it certainly feels like it
you know what you know what it's like
you get engaged in something a deep
conversation a piece of music a piece of
art something you love doing someone you
love being with you get engaged in that
you lose your sense of temporality and
you don't pop out of it and think oh my
God I wish I would use the time frame
that made everything irrelevant because
of my you know know cognitive Brilliance
you think hey we could do that some more
like how about all the time
and that's that's a good goal it's like
yeah how about that all the time and
then you've got time right when you're
engaged like that and I would say that's
a profound neurophysiological signal
that you're in the right place at the
right time right because it's
accompanied by a sense of deep
well-being and that's literally an
antidote to suffering I I mean that
literally it's but with many of my
clients who were suffering
what we would strive to do was not so
much make them happy because sometimes
that was impossible they were so
crippled in in so many ways often
physically and in pain
but something meaningful
I would keep them going
and keep them from straying and keep
them from thinking
homicidal and genocidal thoughts all of
that that meaning that's the antidote to
suffering and the question is well how's
that best to be found well that's an
empirical question you have to you have
to look in your own life and see where
meaning glimmers and then pursue that
right that's what Harry Potter is doing
by the way when he's chasing the snitch
just
thought I'd let you know and and you
know you win the game if you catch that
thing
well that's not exactly right you get
100 points but you know it'll do of
course you're going to be disenchanted
because you were young and naive and so
being disenchanted is part of maturing
but the next part of maturing is to move
forward optimistically as an axiom of
your faith in mankind and yourself as a
recognition of your moral obligation to
do so
right so now your eyes are open you see
well you know there's a snake in the
garden
and Cain is your brother
well yeah it's always been that way and
welcome to reality
so what do you do you allow that to make
you corrupt and nihilistic
not if you think that it's the
corruption and denialism that's the
problem
so you're obligated to be optimistic in
some sense
despite the evidence
and that's Faith so you know pick up
your cross and stumble uphill
consciously
and you bring back optimism in human
relations by structuring your own to the
best of your possible ability
and that'll expand outward as you become
more competent move through your life be
productive
generous kind Discerning wise educated
you be a good father
to everyone not the tyrant
that resentment breeds in your own heart
and that's an act of moral courage
and that's real maturity
so and and if you want an adventure well
there's one for you you know people have
like three well they have four
fundamental fears one is fear of their
own inadequacy and malevolence that's
that's a big fear man that can really
that can really do you in if you
confront it
accidentally and fully happens to
soldiers sometimes in battle when they
find themselves doing things they can't
believe they do and then we're afraid of
society that would be the oppressive
patriarchy because Society judges us
harshly and and mercilessly in many ways
and we don't like to plummet in the
what would you call it
we don't like to see our reputation
Savaged in front of the groups that we
identify with it's extraordinarily hard
on us emotionally for that to happen
which I wrote about for example in rule
one which is a
chapter at least in part that details
out the fact that the neurochemical
systems that track your comparative
status incompetence hierarchies also
regulate the balance between your
positive and negative emotion such that
if you suffer a social defeat your
proclivity to experience negative
emotion radically increases and your
proclivity to experience positive
emotion radically decreases and people
seriously do not like that and it's no
wonder because who wants to be
completely overwhelmed with sadness and
bitterness and anxiety and resentment
and disappointment and frustration and
grief and then also devoid of happiness
you know it's a very definition of hell
and if a status defeat will increase
that probability then we will fight very
hard to maintain our status positions
which we certainly do that's another
fear and then of course we have the fear
of Nature and we should because of
course nature despite being the
environment and this thing that we
should be striving to protect and
maintain is also trying with all of its
might constantly to make us ill and old
and kill us and is generally very
successful at all three and so there's
every reason to be afraid of Nature and
um
you know one night alone in the bush
will pretty much
convince you of that and then people are
also afraid of the unknown and so those
are the big categories of Terror that
human beings face and to be naked on
stage is to face at least two or three
of those
simultaneously the first thing that you
might want to consider is that the world
is a very complicated place now we've
talked about this before and the way
that you handle there's way too much
complexity for you to handle in its in
its entirety so for example in a room
like this
there's an endless number of phenomena
that you could focus your attention on
right from the sort of macro phenomena
which would be the overall say color or
appearance of the room to the micro
phenomena which would be the details at
the highest level of detail that you're
able to perceive that littered the
landscape anywhere and so one of the
problems that you have to solve when
you're operating in the world is how you
perceive the world and we do that in
part by making I would say that we
perceive low resolution representations
of the world and we also confuse those
with the world so when I'm looking at
you I'm really looking at a low
represent what I perceive consciously as
a low representation low resolution
representation of you right I only see
the front of you to begin with I only
see your surface and
in some sense you know I even perceive
you in some sense as a more or less
uniform color it's hard to tell exactly
what color skin is it's sort of a light
pink roughly speaking but my my
perception is fairly is fairly I don't
know a better way of putting it than low
resolution and I seem to perceive you at
the level of resolution that's uh that's
sufficient the the lowest resolution
that's sufficient to facilitate our
interactions because I don't want to
clutter up my perceptions of you when
we're just talking with excess details
so there's lots of things about you I
don't need to see I certainly can't see
any of your microstructures below the
below the phenomenal level like I can't
tell without tremendous further
investigation What You're Made Of
biologically for example and I certainly
can't perceive the networks of society
that you're engaged in your family or
the other sorts of networks that you're
embedded in I see you here now the front
of you at low resolution and you can
tell that to some degree and we've
talked about this before because if you
see say animated movies that use very
low resolution representations of people
like South Park's a really good example
because the imitate or the animation in
South Park's very iconic and and and and
and simple it actually makes almost no
difference to following the story and so
that shows you how iconic your
perception really is can be replaced by
very simple icons and you instantly
adapt to that you know so we can go and
see The Lego Movie Batman Lego Movie for
example and the fact that it's Batman
which is an abstraction to begin with
and then it's made out of Legos it's
almost irrelevant to following the plot
so some people have compared our
perceptions to the user interface on a
computer you know when you're
interacting with your computer you don't
really interact so to speak with the
computer they're iconic representations
on the screen of the computer that you
interact with and those represent
obviously they share some functional
relationship with what's going on in the
computer but mostly they're there so
that you using your perceptual
structures can interact with the
computer in a manner that's easy for
extremely intelligent Apes roughly
speaking now so one of the problems that
you have to solve in the world because
it's so full of detail and so complex is
how do you actually see the world how do
you actually perceive it and
it isn't really self-evident that that's
a problem
because you think when you look at the
world that it just presents itself to
you but it's a tremendously complicated
problem and that's partly why developing
artificial intelligence systems that can
actually see the world and act in it in
any real way has proved to be a much
more difficult problem than people had
originally supposed because you know we
were told maybe from the early 60s
onwards that such things as speech to
text or object recognition or robots
that could operate in the world were
only two or three years away and well I
mean we're in we're in a situation now
where there are some fairly complicated
robots built but they're still really in
their nascent form and it's because
perceiving the world and then figuring
out how to act and it turns out to be a
much more complicated problem than we
originally thought because the borders
between things are not self-evident and
what level of resolution you should be
perceiving things at for say maximal
functional utility is also not
self-evident it's also tied up very
strangely and in ways we don't
understand with the nature sure of your
embodiment you know so for example we
tend to see things that are handy
because we can pick them up and
manipulate them and we can make use of
them and so to some degree our brains
are evolved to make the world manifest
itself to us in a set of discrete usable
tools that's that's a reasonable way of
thinking about it and they're discreet
and usable because we have a certain
kind of biological platform you know
because we have hands and mouths and
because we walk in a bipedal manner then
it's logical for us to break up the
world in a manner that makes operating
in this body maximally useful but that
doesn't mean that there's a
straightforward one-to-one relationship
between our perceptions of things and
the things themselves quite the contrary
and that's partly of course we know that
because
with any perceptible object like I could
conceptualize you as one thing for all
sorts of purposes but
if I'm trying to solve a complex problem
in relationship to you it's going to be
very difficult to determine how to
conceptualize you so if I'm if you come
to me because you're suffering from a
psychological problem of some sort then
I have to figure out you know is it
organic is it is it there's actually
something physiological wrong with you
and I need to know what level of
analysis I would probably conceptualize
you at is it psychological is it and if
it's psychological is it functional like
do you lack the skills or do you lack
the ability to apply the skills or is
there something really going wrong with
your family or maybe it's even a
reflection of an overarching
sociological problem because we know for
example that when the unemployment rate
goes up one percent psychiatric
hospitalizations go up five percent
and so then you might ask well you know
if you're if there's a huge rise in
depression and anxiety across the
population and at the same time there's
a huge increase in in unemployment you
have to ask yourself what level of
perception would best be suited to solve
that problem because it isn't
self-evident that it's psychological at
the level of the individual anyways my
point is is that perception is a very
difficult problem you're probably not
particularly well suited for jobs that
require a tremendous amount of
transformation of thinking or a
tremendous amount of abstraction but
that doesn't mean there are no jobs for
you
and so jobs that are more stable and
repetitive
routine let's say you're better suited
for
vocational
jobs and there's vocational jobs
play and a remarkably important role in
our culture
so and hard work could get you a long
ways
and so you know I don't know what you
mean when you say low intelligence
you know I mean there are
catastrophically low intelligence
ratings say 60 and below
it's tough to find anything that you're
going to be able to be productive
in doing
and I don't know what to do about that
above that hard work is going to make a
huge difference
and aiming right so
aim at the vocation land of the
distribution
and put a plan in place
and stick to it and work diligently at
it that's what you've got you've got
your ability to work
and maybe you can capitalize on your
other personality attributes as well and
as I said already in this podcast you
can do a personality test and understand
myself.com I would also say on my
self-authoring.com website There's an
opportunity for you to map out a plan
and this one of the to map out a plan to
write about your past but also to write
about your present self so the present
authoring program enables you to
do an inventory of your personality
strengths and weaknesses and
there's a virtues analysis and a false
analysis and I would say if you're leery
about your future for whatever reason
you should do the virtues analysis it's
like what have you got to offer
and hopefully you have the ability to
work hard and maybe you have other
personality attributes that are
important and that you could understand
and then capitalize on so I would say do
the understandmyself.com personality
test do the virtue section of the
present authoring exercise at self
authoring.com put together a plan and
aim at the vocational end of the job
distribution don't despair there's
plenty of opportunity at that level for
someone who's honest which is a huge
Advantage who has Integrity who's
willing to work hard
I'm not going to sugarcoat it you know
life is harder at the shallow end of the
gene pool let's say to use scars phrase
from The Lion King we're all at the
shallow end of the gene pool in some
regard you know
so the cognitive end is that's a rough
hit
but
General cognitive ability isn't
everything even though it's a lot of
things
and so
aim Integrity hard work a plan
that's what you've got
and so you have to make the best of it I
continually ask my
frequently let's say or yearly ask my
personality class attendees
if they heard
the voice of conscience if they had a
feeling an emotion emotional state let's
say or of voice that informed them when
they had done something ethically wrong
and that perhaps made them guilty as a
consequence and
it was essentially a universal
experience and that's the voice of
society within I suppose that's one way
of thinking about it the freudians would
think about that as the voice of the
superego Jung Carl Jung would take that
conceptualization somewhat farther he
would have considered it the voice of
the self which is in part
the voice of the ethic that's derived
from the broader Community insofar as
that ethic is valid let's say but also
in part
the voice of the more
thoroughly developed self that's still
striving to be born one thing you could
say is that
you you experience violations of your
conscience when
you're not acting like the better person
that you could possibly become
and so to some degree that's your higher
self upgrading you for failure to
develop in the appropriate Direction
and that seems to me to be
a reasonable way of conceptualizing it
now the one question might be how
error-prone is your conscience given
that you're not omniscient and
I have an endless fascination with the
movie Pinocchio uh and part of that is
because it taught me something very
sophisticated about conscience in that
movie
Jiminy Cricket is given Divine
attributes he has the same initials as
Jesus Christ for example and
um
he is deemed the voice of conscience
Itself by by the magical properties of
of Mother Nature essentially but in the
movie it's necessary for the puppet
who still wouldn't headed and still a
marionette whose strings are being
pulled by others it's necessary for the
puppet to engage in a dialogue with his
conscience because both of them have to
inform the other
and that seems to me approximately right
because I certainly saw people in my
clinical practice and know people in my
private life who seem to labor under a
two authoritarian
labor under the dictates of a two
authoritarian conscience
maybe that's the internalized voice of a
relatively tyrannical father for example
um
or you know exaggerated sensitivity to
the moral pressure exerted by the
broader social world
you have to
attend to your
guilt and yourself disgust and your
self-contempt and your
self-consciousness you have to
understand that the manifestation of
those emotions might well indicate a
moral failing on your part or a
uh
uh a lack that needs to be addressed
while at the same time considering that
it is not a straightforward matter to
deal fairly with yourself and
you can be too tormented by your
conscience too rigid too responsible
take on too much weight onto yourself
deny yourself in a manner that isn't
sustainable
and so forth that that a moral code a
moral way of being can become too rigid
and
and inflexible and despite its putative
aim upward
be something counterproductive I think
most of
the way out of that if there is one is
well careful thinking
you have to see what your conscience
says you have to see how you respond you
have to capture
that voice and your responses and and
you have to think it through but most of
that is done in dialogue with other
people rather than as the consequence of
internal thought
you know if you have a dispute with your
wife or your husband your intimate
partner sibling your parents anybody
close to you
and it's useful to for each of you in
the dispute too
ask yourself and the other person very
seriously
if you're at fault
or if they're at fault and and for both
of you to be able to contemplate
that you might be at fault and so might
the other person and then it's in your
best interest to sort out exactly
who's made the error and where and maybe
it's both of you and maybe at different
levels of analysis
um I think the same might be said about
your reaction to your conscience
it's not uncommon for me to talk to my
wife my kids my parents
my friends for that matter
about something I might be feeling maybe
I'm guilty about something I'm
self-conscious about something I'm angry
about something
um I feel impelled by my conscience to
do something as a consequence
to change something
ah
it's very helpful to discuss such things
with other people to say look here's
what I think I did wrong and here's how
I'm punishing myself but I'm not sure
that I'm not doing it in an exaggerated
way and
you gather other people's opinions and
listen to them carefully and
friends are extraordinarily useful in
that regard
and that can help you calibrate it
so I think most of what we do to decide
if our inner voice is healthy is discuss
it with other people and I believe as I
pointed out in my last book
explicitly that tremendous amount of our
sanity is maintained as a consequence of
social interaction
so
you can't find your authentic self
merely as a consequence of a journey
within I would say you you're not
there's just not enough of you you have
to be informed by the broader social
world if you want an answer to the first
question
which is how do I find the person who's
right for me you actually start by
asking the second question which is what
can I bring to the table for someone
else and if you're really good at
bringing something to the table for
someone else hey man people might be
lining up to be your partner and if
they're not then you might think well
maybe I'm just not bringing the right
thing to the table
and that's worth thinking especially if
you're desperate you're lost and you're
alone it's like hmm maybe I got this
wrong and you know I usually sort of top
that with a suggestion that even if you
did find the person who was perfect for
you and they're that perfect what makes
you think they wouldn't take one look at
you and run screaming away and they
likely would if they were that perfect
because you know really are you that
much of a catch
and if you think you are you know that
might be part of the problem
um
so so look so that's one right intimate
relationship so I would say to you at
the crossroads develop a vision for your
relationship how do you bear
the suffering that is at the Crux of
life
without becoming tempted and embittered
that's really really difficult now you
know someone might point out go ahead
and be bitter see where that gets you
and if you have any sense and generally
people have at least some they know that
being sick and bitter is worse than just
being sick and that being right it's
worse but it's very hard temptation to
avoid sometimes you want to be bitter
just out of spite in some sense because
things are so terrible all you've got
left is your willingness to shake your
fist you know and say well you know
really is this like this many poisonous
snakes really that's like maybe I could
have learned with just one or two not a
hundred and so but we're stuck we're all
stuck with that and I think we're stuck
with it at every level of our life in
some senses how do we maintain a high
order moral orientation in spite of
suffering and malevolence I first
started to understand that
what we perceive in some real sense
isn't exactly material reality and
partly that's because that's actually
impossible
and I mean that technically and that's
something we could go into in great
depth because that realization paralyzed
a number of fields it really started to
come to the Forefront in many fields in
about in the early 1960s especially in
AI when the AI type started to try to
make machines that could see the world
in some sense like we do and then act in
the world and what they instantly
realized was that oh
there isn't just something there that we
see this is way harder than we ever
possibly imagined in fact it's so hard
that it looks like it might be
impossible in some sense so how the hell
do we do it and like we still don't have
robots that can move around the world
like we do you know endless Generations
I'm not I'm not maybe it's improved the
last time I looked at this great detail
we didn't have robots that could fold
laundry very efficiently either so yeah
well a lot of these so-called simple
things like seeing well it's half your
brain it takes you half your brain to
see and most animals like we see way
better than almost all animals say
Eagles Raptors really because bald
eagles in my back yeah they can see they
they their eyes are the same size as
yours and they have two phobia spots
Eagles uh Falcons they're the animals
that can see better than us but other
than that
it's us and it's half our brain just to
see well so why well you're a physicist
you understand that reality is composed
of levels of being right from the
subatomic up to the cosmic it's like
well first of all how do you specify the
proper level of analysis
well one of the things that's quite
interesting psychologically is that we
have short words
are generally used to describe things
that manifest themselves to us at our
level of analysis cat we see a cat we
don't see a species we don't see Cats
sub parts we see this cat well why well
that's that's the level that's most
biologically relevant to us given our
embodiment that's an evolutionary answer
and so we see what we see first of all
what we see a lot of is memory but we
see something that's overlaid on the
world we actually see the overlay and
hopefully it reflects what's underneath
and generally it does and it's a hell of
a shock to us when when we make a
perceptual error
but I see I and then I started to learn
especially from Reading Jeffrey gray
that we we also see the world within a
motivated frame
and he was influenced by Norbert weiner
who was one of the world's first
cybernetic scientists essentially a
great influence on AEI yeah and and gray
never talked about narrative but the
frame that he described that we see and
in animals as well basically has a point
a and a point B so we're always moving
towards a goal if we're mobile animals
and I thought Oh Well the description of
the movement from point A to point B
that's the simplest unit of meaning
that's a story
and then I learned that a better story
is a story about how stories transform
and so those are actually perceptual
frames of reference that transform and
then I understood that
if you don't have respect for the
transformation process above all else
then you can't transform your perceptual
frames when necessary and then you can't
adapt to error and that destroys you and
so that's that's all part of that when
you see people who are Noble in spite of
their suffering it is ennobling it is
uplifting right like really it is and
um and it's been striking to me too
people want to be encouraged in that
direction I mean part of the reason that
my lectures I would say have been
successful to the degree that they have
been is because people find them
encouraging and that actually seems to
work like it seems to be positive
because it is good news well it seems to
be I mean it isn't necessarily the case
that that would be the case you know
because it could have been that I would
have said encouraging things to people
there's more to you than meets the eye
and you're capable of more than you're
demanding of yourself and you know if
you took on your responsibility and face
the things that you're trying to avoid
that your life would be richer and
better and for you and for everyone
around you and the result of that could
have been that thousands of people would
come to me and say you know I gave that
a pretty good shot and it your advice is
really awful and everything is well
seriously like I took on that
responsibility it just bloody crushed me
and I'm way worse off than I was before
and everything's gone to hell around me
and like thanks a lot buddy and that and
that it's not like that's a completely
incomprehensible possibility but that
doesn't seem to be what happens is what
generally happens is that young people
in particular but not only come to me
and say look I've been trying to take on
more responsibility and to face the
things I've been avoiding and everything
is way better it's like okay well isn't
that something to be onto something well
then you ask yourself well what's the
limit of that because that's the
religious question fundamentally is well
if you took on all the responsibility
you couldn't take on
then you faced everything that you
needed to face
what would you be like who would you be
and how would the world transform around
you and well if if the partial answer is
well if I do that a little bit things
get a fair bit better then the next
question might be well
what if you did that completely
and I don't think that's possible in
some sense right it's like you know
Perfection is a horizon that always
recedes but it isn't obvious to me
what the upper limit of that is and
certainly we do see people I mean Saints
right it's a Francis Embassy you kind of
pushed the limit and they miraculous
things happen around them and maybe in
the literal sense and if not in the
literal sense close enough you know for
all intents and purposes and so that's
heartening I mean I
tear myself apart about this in many
ways because I think
perhaps it's possible to take on too
much responsibility and to crush
yourself as a consequence maybe that's a
sin of Pride who knows it's certainly
possible but my experience so far has
been that
when you see people bear their suffering
nobly
there's nothing in that but good
not something and then when you see
people take on more responsibility and
decide that they're going to aim up and
and
confront their suffering honestly and
forthrightly that their lives get better
and the lives of people around them get
better too
and so it's that's very strange as well
because it also means that the pathway
to less suffering
is through suffering
right and that's kind of that would be
hopeful if the world was constituted
that way it's like well there's
suffering how do you make it worse run
away
how do you make it better confront it
yeah but it's suffering it's like yeah
but it's there there it is it's right
there it's a precondition for existence
or something like that and it's like you
have something important to do as well
and you confront it and that's the
pathway to transcending it I was
watching this movie King Arthur by Guy
Ritchie and when when the new king young
King Arthur takes his sword he has
flashbacks to his evil Uncle killing his
father and it just it's so terrible that
he can't hold on to the sword
and I thought well what's Richie doing
there it's well that's the case for all
of us isn't it because when we look into
the past and we see our evil uncles it's
just a complete bloody catastrophic Mass
isn't it slavery and genocide and War
and oppression and like and that's on
all of us isn't it and it's always
lurking there in the background and so
is that male power well yes in some ways
I mean if you don't give a man a sword
he can't use a sword right so not giving
him a sword is one way of making sure
he's peaceful but it's not the it's not
the optimal way and besides if you
[ __ ] men they become far more
dangerous
they've become dangerous in an UNT
terrible underground fashion of course
the same is exactly true a few crippled
women but we're speaking particularly of
boys because I suppose there's an
education crisis among boys and young
men
well you want to encourage that power
because it's actually a tremendous Force
for good if it's brought under control
and so but that's a hard thing to get
right and it also requires a lot of
trust and work on the part of women
because they want to it's like Beauty
and the Beast right because beauty
entices that Beast who's a real who's
real but uncivilized and dangerous she
sort of entices him into becoming
fully developed and that's what a woman
has to do when she you know has that
work project that she marries or has a
long-term relationship with
but
it's much better to encourage with with
faith and trust first of all I do
believe that I don't think science is
possible outside of an encompassing
judeo-christian ethic
so for example I don't think you can be
a scientist without believing as an
axiom of faith that truth will set you
free or that will set us free so we
don't know the conditions under which
science is possible you know and we tend
to overestimate its
epistemological potency it's only been
around I mean you can stretch it back to
the Greeks if you're inclined but in a
formal sense it's only been around for
about five centuries and it's only
thrived for a very short period of time
and it's perfectly reasonable to assume
that there were particular preconditions
that made its rise and descendancy
possible it is a historical phenomenon
yes it happened at a specific moment in
time right and for and at least
yeah and I think one of the conditions
well there's a bunch of them one is for
example there there's an intense
insistence in the Christian tradition
that the mind of God in some sense is
knowable yes so we could say well the
structure of the cosmos and you have to
believe that that's the case before
you're going to embark on a scientific
Endeavor you have to believe that
there's some relationship between logos
logic let's say but logos is a much
broader concept than logic that's for
sure you have to believe that there's
some relationship between that and the
structure of the cosmos you have to
believe that the pursuit of Truth is in
itself an ethical good because why would
you otherwise bother you have to believe
that there is such a thing as an ethical
good and those aren't scientific those
are not scientific questions which is
why I think the arguments of people like
Hitchens are weak it's like yeah
Hitchens Dawkins people like that they
have a metaphysic which they don't know
and they assume that metaphysic is
self-evidence like well sorry guys it's
actually not self-evident and they
assume that it can be derived from the
observations of empirical reality and
the answer to that is
no there's going to be axioms of your
perceptual system that aren't derivable
from the contents of your perceptual
system and you might think well that's
not very scientific and I would say well
take it up with Roger Penrose and see
what he thinks
because I just talked to him for like
three hours about partly about this
topic about say the role of
Consciousness and and the structure of
Consciousness and it's by no means
obvious that the materialist
reductionists have the correct
theory about the nature of Consciousness
and not surprisingly it's like we we
don't understand the relationship
between Consciousness and being at all
and so they're you know these are hard
hard questions well they're the hardest
the hard question for Consciousness
researchers is uh why is there
Consciousness rather than why aren't we
just unconscious mechanisms acting
deterministically they call that the
hard question I don't think that is the
hard question I think the hard question
is what's the relationship between
Consciousness and being itself and
because I don't I can't understand what
it means for something to be in the
absence of some awareness of that being
so when we say being there's an
awareness component implicit in the in
the idea of being itself Consciousness
is integrally tied up with being in some
mysterious Manner and so
and I also don't believe that the the
most sophisticated scientists are by
necessity reductionist materialists like
get as far as you can with that no
problem it's it's Occam's razor clear if
you can reduce and account
deterministically no problem but don't
be thinking that accounts for everything
because I don't think there's any
evidence that it does so imagine that
you're in Amsterdam during World War II
and the Nazis are everywhere and you
have a Jewish Family in the attic and
you're up there with a baby and there's
25 Nazi officers on the ground floor the
baby starts to cry
do you smother the baby you save all the
people upstairs and Claire who is a
mother of a very young child at that
time said her response was don't ask me
such stupid questions which I think is
actually the right response and it's
more embodied response right and you you
can trap your philosophical cognition
into weird corners but that doesn't mean
that your fundamental intuitions are
affordable this is right with this nosik
thing it's it's like well if you could
not have a body yeah you know you're
grounded out in the world that's that's
the rejection of Derek parfitt right so
Derek parfitt's entire moral theory is
the trolley problems and you can decide
how morality is constructed based on
trolley problems and people like well
that's not really how morality is
constructed it's not all based on edge
cases not really how it's constructed at
all it has to be embodied for example
and that's a crucial issue you know and
so the the notion that a set of semantic
philosophical propositions even
coherently organized constitutes the
ethical world and that ethics is top
down from magic space into your body
space that's there's some truth in that
because there's feedback loops right we
think about ethics and we can we can
move around the edges of ethics and so
forth but it's within a game that's
already established and that game is
actually established through embodied
negotiation first so when you see Moses
leading his people through the desert
they're all fighting and scrapping away
right and then he sits as judge of them
for a very long period of time it's
months or years even so much that his
father-in-law says you have to stop
doing this because it's exhausting you
right it's after that he receives the
revelations from on high and so my sense
of that psychologically is it's a story
about the fact that morality is encoded
in our behavior in a deep level and so
deep we actually don't understand the
morality but then now and then we get an
imaginative insight into the moral
pattern and then we get a semantic
representation of the imaginative
insight and that's this Revelation it's
like here's a moral rule it's like
wolves suddenly becoming semantically
conscious of the Authority relationships
in their pack oh that's really good I
like that a lot yeah that's quite good
like 20 years ago
put a lot of effort into that yeah no
there's a there's a there's a big kind
of Rich debate in Jewish philosophy over
whether Moses is right to listen to
Jethro so Jethro comes and says you need
to you need to devolve authority to
lower levels you need the the prince you
need the judges of the tens and then the
judges the hundreds yeah yeah which is a
lovely way of thinking about it too
because it parse out I thought that's
what should have happened in Iraq right
kill the Tyranny well what do you do you
have to establish a hierarchical local
Authority exactly so centralized control
doesn't work but one of the big
questions is whether in doing that is
Moses setting the stage for all of the
chaos that follows because once you give
up the authority that he has the direct
Authority and you have now layers of of
authority below him how much Authority
can you devolve to layers below you
without giving up the the prime
Authority at the top right that is like
one of the Cardinal questions of life
isn't it you know if you have a family
you want to devolve a Authority and
facilitate autonomy and the question is
how much can you do that without without
generating disunity and I would say it
depends on the value of the goal that
unites you and and then that brings up
another question and this is a question
I would say for the moral relativists
um I was talking to Rupert sheldrake in
in Cambridge he has lots of wild ideas
but
I was conducting a seminar there on the
nature of the uniting ideal so it was
imitation of the Divine ideal say you
need a higher order aim to unite
subordinate drives right so the question
then is what becomes the highest order
epic great it's like the pyramid with a
gold cap on the top or the Washington
Monument with a pyramid on top of it
with this aluminum cap on something's at
the top and the thing that's at the top
is actually qualitatively distinctive
from all the things that are subordinate
to it so the question is well what's
that highest order uniting principle and
well one answer to that that the three
religions that are based on books have
proposed is it has something to do with
the authority of the word and
Christianity that's developed into the
notion of the Divine word and you see
that saturating Judaism as well and
that's at least in part because the
thing that has to be superordinate is
freedom of
it's not freedom of fight exactly it's
more like freedom of Consciousness
because logos isn't thought it's not
logic either it's much broader than that
it's more like Consciousness itself and
the reason I think that's true
technically is because we imagine that
Consciousness and attention are in some
sense isomorphic right I mean when we
pay attention to something we become
conscious of it okay Consciousness
Consciousness is the mechanism that
generates proximal Solutions and
dissolves and regenerates them and so
all the proximal Solutions have to be
made subordinate to respect for the
process that generates old okay yeah
yeah exactly well I think it's a
cardinal
presupposition of psychotherapy because
what you do in Psychotherapy is you
allow people maximal freedom of
expression right you don't impose your
views on them you the freudians use free
association say whatever comes into your
mind and it turns out that that process
of
untrammeled expression in good faith is
actually Curative it actually makes
people better it leads them to what
they're afraid of that that's one of the
consequences of of free speech right
because you sort of you tend to
circulate around what bothers you and
what disturbs you and so untreambled
freedom of expression will lead you to
the source of your fears and then you
can confront those fears and then in
confronting them you can get more
courageous that's all part of that the
other thing that that ideology does and
the radical leftists are all also very
good at this is that
it provides you with a local a
convenient Locale for the for the uh
existence of evil
and so if you reflexively identify the
patriarchy with evil
well first of all that's a powerful idea
it it independent of its broad Merit
it's a it's true
now it's not the only truth and it's not
the complete truth but it's true the
reason it's true is because every
hierarchical system hierarchical system
degenerates tends to degenerate in the
direction of power and all hierarchical
systems are less than they could be and
that's partly because of the possibility
that power and deceit will corrupt them
but also partly because we're willfully
blind and deceitful in our own personal
lives and so when you tell young people
that
the cause of the trouble they see around
them in the world and maybe even the
disquiet in their own heart is the
malevolent inadequacy of their society
that Rings true and they don't hear the
rest of the story you know and it's the
rest of the story that I've been trying
to tell they don't hear the story that
yeah don't forget about the evil and
Corruption that exists in your own heart
and don't forget about the fact that
nature
in this wondrous goddess as portrayed by
the anti-human environmentalists and I
by that I don't mean all
environmentalists by the way
that wonderful goddess nature is also
trying to
make you ill and kill you at all times
and so but the story that corruption
exists in hierarchical structure
and that that's a consequence of
malevolence the malevolent use of power
and deceit that's true
so it's very motivating especially if
you're young and you're looking for an
invention now it's also too convenient
which is one of its tremendous dangers
Because unless you're taught to look
within and identify the malevolence
there as the primary moral obligation
then you now have an excuse and a moral
justification to take out all of your
negative emotion your hostility your
resentment everything about you that's
unexamined on the Demonic Enemy and of
course that's that that degenerates with
extraordinary rapidity as we've seen
over and over and over
so it's up to the it's up to the
centrists on both sides to to deal with
this I've been talking to a lot of The
Optimist rationalist Types on my podcast
Matt Ridley and Bjorn lomberg and well
and height and and Pinker more more
distantly but more recently uh Bloomberg
and and Ridley and and uh Marion tupi
who who's written a lovely book on uh
human progress uh 10 things everyone
needs to know about human progress it's
something like that huh anyways
one of the things we discussed
consistently was the difficulty in
promoting
the message that all three of these men
are very aware of which is that from a
material perspective in terms of
absolute privation
worldwide
humanity is way better off on virtually
every Dimension you could possibly
measure than ever and and most of that
Improvement has occurred in the last 40
years and it's been revolutionary in its
speed and no one knows this
and so it's very important to note to
try to think through why that is like
that's such a positive message now I
talked to Russell Brand about this and
I'm bringing him up for a reason he's
he's a lefty by temperament and by heart
and his first objection but he's very
thoughtful and quick his first objection
you know I pointed out all this data
showing that by every possible objective
measure everything is way better than it
was
certainly a hundred years ago but
certainly even 20 years ago
um even on the environmental front in
the main
and he said well what about disparity of
distribution so there's the problem of
absolute level of wealth let's say
that's improving but there is still
tremendous disparity and of course that
that is fair enough you could even point
out that the role of the left is to
provide a conscientious voice for
for that's constantly attending to the
fact of continuing disparity regardless
of absolute level of wealth and and fair
enough but
but having said all that
it's a great mystery that incremental
optimism is not sufficiently motivating
and you can't just wish human nature is
going to change it's not going to change
we got to tell a better story and I also
think that's why I'm a Target
I think is because I am actually trying
to tell a better story and I'm actually
having some success with it I think
faith is a form of courage
you know if you're hurt by life and you
will be
it's understandable that you might react
in a nihilistic and hopeless fashion and
become anxious and depressed and cynical
and bitter and all of that
uh that's a bad pathway
and I think part of what helps you
through that is Faith and and part of
that faith is that it's incumbent upon
you and actually in your best interest
and everyone else's to maintain faith in
the fundamental goodness of existence
including your own despite the evidence
to the contrary
right because you can draw conclusions
from suffering in two ways right one is
that you have a duty and perhaps the
capability to transcend to suffering is
still serve the good or you can derive
the conclusion that life is so
unbearable that it would be best
terminated which is the conclusion that
girth is Mephistopheles derives for
example in Faust he says well the world
is Rife with suffering and it's so
unbearable that Consciousness itself all
being should cease to exist that would
be better nothing is better than
something if something is right with
suffering and you can derive that
conclusion and you'll be driven to it in
some
[Music]
of the farther reaches of your life when
terrible things happen to you but I
would say
faith is the courage to not take that
path despite the evidence that that
might be justified
and so I think it is a form of courage
in the highest sense and I also think it
is a redeeming form of courage one of
the things I told my daughter who was
very very ill for a very long period of
time and in tremendous pain and
suffering the high probability of
continued slow painful inevitable
degeneration was
do not let your illness do not take
advantage of your illness as an excuse
and I told her that when she was in
grade two you know it's no joke to tell
someone that because I knew she'd had
every reason to be embittered but I also
knew that if she was
in combination with realness the two
things might be worse than fatal and you
know if you don't think there are things
that are worse than fatal you have not
suffered because there are things that
are much worse than fatal and that's
certainly not something you want to do
near a child to so one of the things
I've been talking to my audiences about
is the relationship between
responsibility and meaning which is what
would you say it's a it's a constant
refrain in the book it's one of its
underlying
messages let's say or
themes is a better way of thinking about
it
you know if you start with the
presumption that there's a baseline of
suffering in life and that that can be
exaggerated by as a consequence of human
failing as a consequence of malevolence
and betrayal and self-betrayal and
deceit and all those things that we do
to each other and ourselves that we know
that aren't good that amplifies the
suffering that's sort of the Baseline
against which you have to work and and
and it's contemplation of that often
that makes people hopeless and depressed
and anxious and overwhelmed and all of
that and and they have the reasons but
you need something to put up against
that and what you put up against that is
meaning meaning is actually the Instinct
that helps you guide yourself through
that catastrophe and most of that
meaning is to be found
in the adoption of responsibility
so if you think for example if you think
about the people that you admire well
you think about when you have a clear
conscience first because that's a good
thing to aim at which is something
different than happiness right
um a clear conscience is different than
happiness that's better yeah that's
better guilting yourself you're not
feeling bad about yourself that's right
you feel that you've Justified you've
Justified your existence right and so
you're not waking up at three in the
morning in a cold sweat thinking about
all the terrible things that you've
involved yourself in what you said to
someone that you shouldn't have said or
are you acted or what opportunity you
lost or or or or yeah or or the things
that you've that you've let go that you
should have capitalized on and all of
that and so if you think about the times
when you're at peace with yourself with
regards to how you're conducting
yourself in the world it's almost always
conditions under which you've adopted
responsibility right at least the most
the most guilt I think that you can
experience perhaps is the sure knowledge
that you're not even taking care of
yourself so that you're leaving that
responsibility to other people because
that's pretty pathetic and I unless
you're Psychopathic and you know and
you're living a parasitical life and
that that characterizes a very small
minority of people and an even smaller
minority think that's justifiable but
most of the time you're in guilt and
shame because you're not you're you're
not
only are you not taking care of yourself
let's say so someone else has to but
you're not living up to your full
potential and so there's a existential
weight that goes along with that I came
about the idea is that I'm going to
relate to you
by a variety of roots uh
oh
[Music]
conducting investigations in a variety
of disciplines
uh scientific disciplines to the degree
I was capable of doing now time
inquiries into
literary reality
because literature has its reality I
mean not only its existence as
literature which is obviously real but
in what it portrays which is very
interesting because we all know that
literary portrayals are fictional and we
all know that fiction isn't true
but we all know that literature is true
and deep literature is particularly true
and so that's seems to pose somewhat of
a problem
um I came to the ideas that I'm
discussing too because I noted the
emergence of a problem across multiple
disciplines and it's a very serious
problem in fact I would say it's a
problem so serious that it took
three and a half billion years of
evolution to solve
um
and that would be the problem of
perception
you know the world is given to us in our
perceptions and we confuse the world
that we perceive with the actual world
and
we have to because
we're stuck with
our limited and ignorant perceptions and
so
it's necessarily the case that we bump
up hard against the underlying reality
that those perceptions are trying to
represent
I read a paper in the MIT Handbook of
cognitive science a while back it wasn't
the first place I'd encountered this
idea but it was stated pretty briefly
and so it's a good way of laying out the
problem the problem is really one of
interpretation and it bedeviled
or artificial intelligence researchers
who were attempting to
produce functional robots that could
operate in real world environments and
you'll know we have none of those yet
although we are getting much closer
um it bedeviled cognitive scientists and
and psychophysiologists who are trying
to understand visual perception which
turns out to be complicated Beyond
Comprehension I mean we devote about
half our brain it's really more than
that to just seeing
and it's interesting to
contemplate why that might be if the
world in some sense is given and
composed of
self-evidently apprehensible objects
which it's not
at all
and the problem also emerged in literary
criticism and interestingly enough it's
emergence there
sparked I would say
the culture war that we're all engaged
in at the moment and so this is not a
trivial problem and
the MIT researchers that I described met
in an Aguilar said
it is possible to categorize a finite
number of objects in an infinite number
of ways
and you think well that doesn't sound
like too serious a problem but it's
actually a really serious problem
because it means that any
snapshot of reality let's say any visual
snapshot of reality certainly any
conceptual snapshot of reality like a
book
is subject to an unending number of
potential interpretations and we could
perhaps quibble about whether that's
actually infinite but I don't think
that's really matters there's all sorts
of mathematical discussions about the
true nature of infinity and
that's the point the point is there are
lots of them way more than you could
ever sort through
and so how how do you do it
and how do you do it in such a mat in a
manner that really makes it simple in
some sense because there's the step and
there it is and I walk down and no
problem except like I said took three
and a half billion years to evolve the
platform that made that perception
possible and so if it took God himself
you know three and a half billion years
to manage it then it's a rather
difficult problem to solve
thank you
so I started studying cybernetics
neuropsychology
animal behaviorism
literary Theory psychoanalytic theory
existential philosophy biblical studies
physics to a limited degree evolutionary
biology evolutionary psychology
measurement Theory construct validation
Theory all these different diverse
domains of inquiry
trying to triangulate this problem
although more than triangulate because I
was using more than one reference point
it's a good methodological it's a good
method by which to proceed if you can
find an answer that manifests itself in
multiple historically detached
disciplines simultaneously it's some
evidence that that idea is valid you're
you do that with your senses you have
five senses if all five senses which are
quite qualitatively distinct
point to the same thing then you can be
reasonably but not certainly sure that
it's there
up by reasonably but not certainly I
mean
if that was all there was to specifying
the objects of perception properly we
wouldn't have to talk to each other and
find out what other people think
but we do because even with that
quintangulation let's say
we still Orient ourselves unreliably in
the world what I think is at the core of
the postmodern critique
um I don't think you can look at the
world except through a structure of
value and the the English so you think
well how did the why is literary
criticism so relevant well or become so
relevant and so powerful and I think
well
I believe that we see the world through
a narrative framework
and so that if that's true and we could
talk a little bit about that what I mean
by that I think you need a mechanism to
prioritize your attention
and to because attention is a finite
resource and it's costly so you have to
prioritize it and there's no difference
between prioritizing your attention and
imposing a value structure those are the
same thing and then I think that the
mechanisms that we use to prioritize our
attention are stories and that means
that the people who criticize our
stories actually have way more power
than you think because they're actually
criticizing the mechanism through which
we look at the world and so the
postmodernists would say look you even
look at the scientific world through a
value-laden lens and I think yeah you do
uh they're right but what they're not
right about is that the lens is one of
power and now for someone like Nietzsche
the thing about a word like power is you
can expand the thing the borders of the
word to Encompass virtually any
phenomena you want and so that's why I
tried to Define power as my willingness
to use compulsion on you or other people
because power can be Authority power can
be competence I don't mean any of that I
mean you don't get what you to do what
you want I get to tell you Coors exactly
and uh and I do think the Marxist types
view the willingness to use coercion as
the driving force of human history and
that's really saying something because
that means it's the fundamental
motivation and uh that's a very caustic
criticism and it's easy to put people
back on their heels about that you know
one of the things you see about
capitalists because I've been stunned to
see the CEOs of major corporations like
roll over in front of these Dei
activists I think well what the hell is
wrong with you people you know you're
not even making use of your privilege
and why are you
um well it's not very powerful if you're
the CEO of a major corporation you can't
even withstand some interns who have Dei
ideology it's like it's doing you a lot
of good and uh
so
and why would you produce a fifth column
within your organization that's
completely opposed to the entire manner
in which you do business and the
capitalist Enterprise as such and one
answer would be well we don't think much
about ideas it's like well maybe you
should and and you know you can be
cynical about it and say well it's just
a gloss to keep the capitalist
Enterprise going while appearing to to
meet you know the new demands of of
ethical re of the new ethical reality
which I think is a bad argument too but
more importantly it's that people are
guilty
and the the radicals who accuse us all
historically and as individuals of being
motivated by nothing but the desire for
power
strike a chord especially in people who
are conscientious you know because if
you're a conscientious person and
someone comes to you and says like a
little mob of 30 people says you know
you can be a little more careful in what
you say and do on the racist front and
the sexist front Etc
you're likely to think well
I'm not perfect I probably could be a
little more careful and it's no doubt
that people have been oppressed in the
past and it's also no doubt that in some
sense I'm the undeserving beneficiary of
historical atrocity and so you know
maybe I should look to myself and
that's weaponization of guilt and it's
very effective and it's not surprising
but it's not helpful so you know so so
there's a resentment that drives this
like a corrosive resentment that's able
to weaponize guilt and it's very
difficult for people to withstand it for
me as a clinical psychologist I I've
always looked at things I think
in some ways
from the opposite perspective of most
maybe even most psychologists
it's never been a mystery to me why
people are depressed it's never been a
mystery to me why people are anxious and
unsettled it seems obvious why they're
concerned and hurt and anxious and
unsettled I I think the mystery is
how it is that we can conduct ourselves
so that that can remain under control I
mean people deal with very heavy burdens
in their life you know you you don't
have to talk to someone for very long
someone you might be thinking is doing
quite well in the world and and
sometimes people are
but you don't have to scratch very deep
beneath the surface before you find out
that they have a family member who has a
serious illness or someone who's
suffering through a economic crisis of
one form or another or or who there's
some source of genuine tragedy yeah
one degree removed from them if it's
even removed and most people even as
individuals have at least one serious
problem that they're dealing with and so
it's no mystery that people find it
difficult to orient themselves in the
world and the Mystery is well what can
you do about it and
we do know what you can do about it and
you know Jonathan height wrote a book
recently
um
now I'm afraid that it's uh the name of
the book is escape me it's about the
college situation and and the snowflake
culture and um
one of the things that he pointed out
along with Logan off who's his co-author
was that
it if you're a psychotherapist
of any sort
particularly a behavior therapist
what you help people do is to identify
their problems that's the first thing is
to confront what's there the reality of
what's there and as bluntly as possible
and so you often end up as a
psychotherapist talking to people about
their array of problems as it's as if
they're putting their cards on the table
and and you sort out their problems it's
like and no they often decide that many
of the things that are bothering them
are not really that important they can
wait but that there are crucial life
challenges that present themselves to
them and they're not just psychological
problems although sometimes they are
they're they're problems in life right
existential problems and then what you
do is you help people
break them down into manageable units
let's say strategically and confront
them voluntarily you know and there's an
echo of that idea there's an echo of
that in in Christian thinking and the
echo for that is to pick up your cross
voluntarily we which is that you have a
you have a an
unavoidable mortal burden to bear in
life there's no escape from it
except to directly confront it and to
take it on voluntarily and what's so
fascinating about that two things one is
that psychotherapists of every stripe
understand that this is one of the
primary reasons that Psychotherapy works
there's no dispute about that among all
the different psychotherapeutic schools
is that the confrontation of
existential problems voluntary
confrontation is Curative and that's
really something
and so and and and and and and the
Practical aspect of that is quite
straightforward it it it it also
indicates practical and philosophical it
also indicates to you that
there's far more to you than you think
because it turns out that you have
substantial problems genuine deep
problems of malevolence and suffering
but that if you
decide that you will take that on as
your responsibility
that you can put yourself together
psychologically just the courage and you
can actually solve the problems and and
that seems to be true it's it's it's not
a naive wish it seems to be well within
our capacity and I mean that's part of
the message I would say of 12 rules for
life is that dark as things are
there is more light in you than you know
what to do with and there's more light
in you than you can possibly manifest
and and then the way to find that out is
to
challenge yourself against
massive problems and to find out that
you're the one
that can deal with them so you need that
instinct for meaning too so and we
should get this real straight why do you
need it
well you need it because life is really
really difficult right I mean people
have a rough time of it there's plenty
of suffering in life and everyone is
going to encounter it right there you
don't you know you learn this as a
clinical psychologist and you know this
generally you know unless you're an
extraordinarily fortunate person
um you don't have to talk to someone for
very long and and really talk to them
and get beneath the surface until you
find you know there's a tragedy or two
or three or ten lurking not very far
beneath the surface someone in the
family is very ill there's a childhood
history of extreme pathology alcoholism
somewhere in the family maybe a touch of
insanity someone has cancer you know
someone someone older relative is dying
there's financial trouble there's
economic trouble there's marital trouble
it's like life is trouble and now you
know that doesn't mean it's all trouble
but man it's trouble and sometimes it's
it's a lot of trouble and sometimes it's
so much trouble that you can you can
barely stand it and and you see that
because people you know people get
depressed and they commit suicide and
the reason they do that is because they
think not being is better than being and
that's quite the decision you know so
and and it's not that uncommon among
people who are depressed and so it's
it's a it's a very it's a very important
thing to consider and it and it isn't
just a matter of depression and suicide
that's bad enough but you know if you're
unhappy because your suffering has
pushed you past the point of your
ability to cope then there's all sorts
of other things that can happen to you
that aren't directed towards you you can
become cynical and you can become bitter
and you can become cruel and you can
become narcissistic and deceitful and
arrogant and and it's like everything's
for you and then you're out for Revenge
that's a nice one I don't know against
who but maybe everyone maybe even
including you because you're not happy
about the rule you've played in
generating your own misery I mean
there's a lot of Darkness underneath the
suffering and so and and that's that's
an ever-present existential danger for
human beings you know we're aware of the
future we're aware of our fragility
we're aware of our mortality it's
something that makes us truly unique
truly conscious in a way that no other
creature is and capable of things that
no other creature can do but also
bearing an unbelievably heavy
existential load were the only creatures
that have to always contend with the
fact that we're finite and that everyone
we know is in the same position that
allied with the suffering and so that's
there all the time and and you know even
even in in the brightest moments in some
sense you know in in Renaissance
paintings in still lifes they used to
put a Memento momento Mori often in the
in the still life like a skull somewhere
in the corner or sometimes sometimes in
in a very strange perspective so that
you could only see this skull if you
were standing like right beside the
painting instead of dead on but the idea
was to always remember you know that
everything that exists is Tainted or
touched with the with the with the with
it with the taint of mortality and you
know that's rough but there's some
useful things in it it keeps you awake
and it keeps you focused if you're
careful but it also does indicate to you
if you think about it the necessity of
having a meaning in your life because
because
if it's true intrinsically that life has
this unbearable element of suffering
which seems to be completely in in what
would you say indisputable as far as I'm
concerned and it's worse than that too
because it's not just suffering it's
suffering contaminated with malevolence
right it's it's bad enough to have
something bad happen to you and it's
likely that that'll happen but it's even
worse for you to do it to yourself and
to know that you did it that's rough and
it's also extraordinarily rough to be
betrayed by someone else or you know
tyrannized by your own culture and so
and that's that's not just suffering
that's like unnecessary and pointless
suffering that's been directed at you by
something that wants that to happen and
so both of those are very very powerful
let's say archetypal forces suffering
and malevolence and we have to deal with
them at every level of reality and you
need something to you need something to
push back against that it's not optional
if that's the D default position and I
think it's the default position like a
meaningless life isn't meaningless
it's suffering and malevolence
that's not good and and if that's acted
out you know that that's the other thing
if that's acted out and I've read the
accounts and the actions of people
who've
taken a very vicious turn into the
darkest parts of the underworld
consequence of their resentment and
their malevolence and then their desire
to make everything in the world suffer
for the outrage of its existence man I
mean that's how we turn things into hell
if you want to know why totalitarian
States take the brutal twists they take
and why people are motivated to do the
absolutely terrible things that they do
well that's why is that the suffering
and the malevolence that's intrinsic to
life overwhelms them and they turn and
they turn in a very bad Direction and
then they make everything that's already
bad way worse and we're very very
inventive at such things and so that's
not good unless that's the path you want
that's a bad idea you need an
alternative and that's meaning part of
the cultural battle that we all find
ourselves enveloped in is partially due
to the claim that there's virtually
nothing other than the lust for power
and you know I would say
fair enough in some limited sense which
and that's
that bears directly on your question
because you see that as a Temptation
that might be powerful enough to bend
and distort you as you attempt to make
your way through let's say the halls of
power
well
[Music]
I heard recently from a reliable source
that Putin's conversion to Orthodox
Christianity might be genuine
and then you might think well if you're
atheistic
well that's not necessarily a good thing
or maybe you think it's a bad thing or
maybe you think it's
an irrelevant issue and you may also
think it's a lie but
I would say that
I would be more inclined to trust
someone who thinks there's something
higher than himself
and then you might say well what is it
that's higher than ourselves and that's
we're thinking about and we all need to
think about this regardless of the
particulars of our religious belief and
I would say
foreign
from a clinical perspective service to
others is really something
people who are depressed tend to use the
pronouns I and me much more frequently
than people who aren't depressed and I'm
not saying that people get depressed
because they're selfish I'm not saying
that at all I'm saying that one of the
way out one of the roots out of
depression appears to be an increase in
service to other people and I think the
reason for that is because we aren't
power mad demons at the core even though
we may be tempted by such things and
that we find the genuine meaning that
offsets genuine suffering in the genuine
service to others and I think it's a big
mistake to be cynical especially
prematurely about such things as
political activity because they're
necessary despite let's say they're
adversarial and uh and uh
party-centered nature partisan nature
you have to be clear about what you
serve and why
and that has to be held higher always
than mere Victory mere
operationalized Victory or instrumental
Victory it's a very very difficult thing
to to negotiate particularly because in
the political Realm
in some sense you have to defeat your
enemy right because you have to win the
election and the other people have to
lose it's a binary choice but so often I
see in partisan discussion the
proclivity to assume that all the ill
will and malevolence resides on the
other side of the chamber and that's a
big mistake and you can think about that
more deeply too is that we all have to
put we all need a place to place the
existence of malevolence
right because malevolence clearly exists
and we're all suffer from the weight of
malevolent history right because even
the grounds we walk on here which this
is a remarkable and wonderful place I
mean English soil is soaked with blood
just like the soil of every place in the
world that's part of the human Heritage
and all of us bear the marks of that
conflict in some sense in our souls
partly because of the possibility for us
to engage in that but also partly
because part of the reason we're here in
all this privilege is because of all
that catastrophe well the best way to
localize that malevolence is inside you
right and to remember that the enemy
that you're fighting with the greatest
enemy that you ever fight with is in
your own heart and that'll also stop you
from confusing that true source of
malevolence let's say with your mere
political enemies and that isn't to say
that you won't encounter malevolent
Behavior although most of it in the
political sphere as it is everywhere
most of it is more ignorance than
malevolence although willful blindness
certainly plays a large role and so you
need to know what it is that you're
serving and I would say one of the ways
to do that practically are a couple of
ways to do that practically is you need
a good team around you the people you
really trust and who can watch you and
who do it with a certain degree of
impartiality and who are disagreeable
enough to talk to you when you do
something wrong so you need trusted
advisors and then the other thing I
would say is you really need to listen
to your constituents
because they will tell you what the
problems are if you listen to them and
if you really listen to them well then
you'll have your feet on the ground
which is where they should be and you'll
know what the problems are and you will
win elections
because what people really want from
their leaders is to be listened to and
then for those leaders to articulate
what they've heard in the halls of let's
say influence and Power and so if you
know those things if you know you need
to listen you need to get in touch with
the people you're representing as
regularly as you possibly can and mostly
to listen
um I knew a man in Canada who started a
political party which is a very
difficult thing to do and not only did
he start it but he wrote it to
sufficient success though that he became
the leader of the opposition in Canada
within about 10 years and I asked him
how he did that because like well really
how did you do that that's actually
really hard and he said he would go out
from constituency to constituency and
make his stump speeches but what he
really liked was the Q and A's because
people would tell him what their
problems were then he knew what the
problems were and out of the dialogue
would also emerge the answers that the
audience found compelling and so not
only would they tell him what the
problems were but they would tell him
the answers they would like to have it
have have what instituted to solve those
problems and it's the same thing that
comedians do when they when they finast
finesse their acts in front of live
audiences before they practice them in
front of a large audience they lit they
tell jokes and the audience see their
laughs or they don't if they laugh then
you keep that joke and if they don't you
throw it out and soon you're just as
funny as the audience can possibly
manage and it's the same thing you can
also do that in a dark manner by the way
which is what Hitler did
so he could utter terrible things and
wait for response and collect those and
so then you become the embodiment of The
Shadow of Your people so I would
recommend that you probably don't do
that human consciousness is that faculty
that confronts potential itself I think
there's good neurological evidence for
this by the way for those of you who are
scientifically minded because
we build
circuits within us for habitual action
that we've practiced many times that
seem to run in a very deterministic
fashion and we are a strange combination
of deterministic and non-deterministic
as far as I can tell but what our
Consciousness seems to be for is to
encounter those things that we have not
yet encountered and those things that we
have not yet encountered seem to me to
be those things that have not yet been
brought into being and so you could say
that what our Consciousness is for is
for the encounter with potential you
know that our Consciousness is for the
it's not for the past it's not even for
the present
it's to transform the future into the
present and then really that that's what
our Consciousness does when you wake up
in the morning you have a new day ahead
of you and the day could take you in
very many directions and and the weeks
and the years all of that can take you
in very many directions and you have
some apprehension about what those
directions might be you have some
apprehension about what role your
choices might make in transforming that
potential into one form of actuality or
another I mean you certainly know that
there are Dreadful mistakes that you
might be very tempted to make that would
produce all manner of hell around you
and still be tempted to do it it seems
like it's sitting there right in front
of you as a possibility you also know
that you know you could haul yourself up
out of bed and attend to your duties and
do the sorts of things that you're
supposed to and said a few things right
that day and that week and that likely
things would at least not be worse and
they would probably be better and I I
believe that I do believe that I don't
understand how this can be the case I
don't understand how it is that
Consciousness Consciousness can function
in that way because I think to
understand that we would have to
understand what it means for the future
to be only potential rather than
actuality and who the hell understands
that I mean no one and then we'd have to
understand how it is that our conscious
choices and our conscious ethical
choices transform that potentiality into
actuality into reality into the present
and the past and we certainly
but we certainly act as if we believe
that that's what we do we upgrade
ourselves for example when we do a bad
job of it we're upset with our children
and those we love if we don't believe
that they're living up to their
potential we're guilty and ashamed when
we make choices that we feel are
inappropriate we understand to some
degree that the manner in which time
lays itself out has something to do with
the ethics of our choice and again I
would say that's a very deep idea I
think it's a I think it's I think it's
the most true idea I know it's very
emphasize that idea emphasized in
ancient religious stories such as those
that are outlined in Genesis or in
Genesis with its strange insistence that
you know God is that which
brings order out of chaos formless
potential generates the world out of
formless potential and that we're
somehow made in that image which which
seems to me to be the case and that the
proper way by the way to go about
acting in that image is to act in
relationship to the potential that
confronts you with truth and with
courage with careful articulation that's
the logos and that if you do that then
what you bring forth is is good you
speak about the concept of the Soul
um do you associate this with any
psychological constructs
not any psychological constructs that
are more valid than the notion of the
Soul
you know there's there's I would say
what we mean by soul is something like
animating spirit
and you might say well what's a spirit
and well that's actually rather easy to
answer so when a child of four is
playing house
let's say when a child of four is
playing house she
acts out the role of the mother
but acting out that's a strange thing
right because she doesn't literally
duplicate in her actions or her
Perceptions in the game what she
observed her mother literally doing so
for example she didn't go into her
mother's bedroom when her mother awoke
and watched her turn her head in a
particular way to awaken and count the
number of blanks so that she could mimic
that in her play and you know you think
that's absurd but it's not absurd if
it's just mimicry it's not it's
unbelievably sophisticated so what the
girl does is she watches her mother
manifest maternal Behavior across a vast
array of instances and she integrates
that with the image of the mother she's
received from all the books she's been
read in all the little movies she's
watched the Disney movies and so forth
and she abstracts out the animating
principle of the maternal and then she
embodies that in play and usually with a
little boy and that's practice for
what's going to come later it's
unbelievably sophisticated and she's
embodying a spirit and the spirit there
is the abstraction of the central
animating principle from multiple
embodiments of its manifest station and
if you think children can't do that well
then you don't know anything about
children because they do that all the
time in their pretend play which is a
necessary precursor to healthy
psychological development and so part of
what we refer to as the soul is the
presence of that Spirit or maybe even
the capacity of embodying such spirits
and it's very difficult to know how deep
that goes
you know I had a vision at one point of
all the men in my life who've been
particularly influential in a benevolent
way
you know and so and you think well just
a mirror notion of the idea that there
could be a benevolent way that would
unite the acts of benevolence across a
series of men that's all comprehensible
to you that's you take that as a matter
of course when you say that there are
such things as good men and you can
identify them right something stable
about whatever is good across multiple
manifestations of of incarnation let's
say and I saw that transform into the
the farther person of the Trinity as the
embodiment of that benevolent Spirit now
I don't have any idea what that means
metaphysically because who does but but
that
that Spirit manifesting itself within is
certainly part of what we refer to when
we talk about the soul and you can see
that shine through people I mean it's
part of what gives someone Charisma it's
part of what elicits the instinct to
imitate in you
you know when you see that even in
simple things when you see a remarkable
athlete do something incredibly athletic
to put the goal to put the soccer ball
the football ball through the net to
score the goal and everybody leaps to
their feet in celebration of that well
that's that's a celebration of the
Divine capacity to hit the target dead
on and it grips you at such a a low
level way down inside your soul that
you're compelled to your feet to cheer
and you don't even know what you're
doing
but you enjoy it that's for sure and
that enjoyment is also a sign of the
depth and utility of that response you
see this in all all the things that
people do that are you know so-called
popular entertainment it's unbelievably
sophisticated
the soul is participating that in the
fullest extent and you know you can say
well there's no use for the religious
there's no necessary use for the
religious terminologies like well until
you come up with a better word there's
plenty of use for it because it's a very
complex and deep phenomena and to you
know just
casted into the realm of superstition in
some casual manner is it's just not
helpful not in any possible it's not
helpful scientifically it's not helpful
ethically it's not helpful existentially
try treating someone for a while as if
they don't have a soul
just really I mean it just you know
treat them like a deterministic machine
if that's your belief
really act it out you'll be like the
most hated person in town in about 15
minutes well I mean what do you make of
practical evidence like that I mean you
interact with people as if they're free
Souls capable of choosing between good
and evil that's what you do all the time
and maybe you can Addle yourself out of
that by some ridiculous rationalist
ideology but that just means you're kind
of a gabbling fool and it's just going
to make you trip over things you don't
even notice in all of your social
interactions and you tell me I don't
care how you think philosophically or
ideologically you bloody well know that
what I just said is true
so and that's true even when you're
interacting with an infant or a small
child it's true when you're dealing with
someone who's elderly and virtually
incapacitated in every way you still see
that Divine spark for lack of a better
term and we do lack a better term by the
way you see that everywhere if your eyes
are open and if you're willing to see it
and to the degree that you're responsive
to that then
your actions are Guided by love and your
words are Guided by truth life has
proximal meanings right there's the
meaning that you experience when you're
engaged in a piece of art or when you're
reading or when you're engrossed in a
movie or in a conversation there's the
meaning that emerges
within your relationships with people
that you cherish or are enthusiastic
with
there's meanings of security and
predictability
uh there's meanings of Duty and
responsibility and active engagement
with your job and your career
um there's meanings of aesthetic
pleasure
now
all of those have their value
and each of them has their place and you
know maybe there's a hierarchy of value
there as well so that some of those
meanings are deeper than others
and then you might say well what
characterized the deepest of all
meanings and it would be something like
relationship with the Transcendent and
that would establish a relationship
between you and
what's always being conceptualized is
God which is generally supposed to be
something ineffable right it's not
definable but you might think about it
as the central animating Spirit of the
age or the value around which all other
values are organized or the wisdom of
the ages or the creative spirit that
possesses you when you're inspired or
what grips you with enthusiasm at a
sports event or at a musical event all
of those things and we need a
relationship with that and we find our
deepest meaning in that relationship and
if we don't find it
I think if we don't find it in something
that's explicitly
religious then we tend to magnify
something of lesser value say something
political into that to fill the void
so yes life has proximal meanings
without god without eternity but
at the ultimate level something's
lacking
and it's the desire to fulfill that lock
that and maybe the lock itself that's
part and parcel of the religious
instinct
so
you can kill God
but you can't
that doesn't rectify the hunger for God
and then that hunger seeks out
Replacements that's how it looks to me
so
and then you know you you might also say
well does that mean you have to believe
in God and uh
I don't think of the proper answer to
that is that you need to agree with a
propositional statement does God exist
yes
no like does this is this table there
yes
it's not that kind of relationship it's
characterized in the Old Testament as a
struggle so Israel means those who
struggle with God
and
you have to participate in that struggle
and you can do that weirdly enough as a
Believer as a non-believer
maybe sometimes more intensely as a
non-believer
the issue might be more Paramount than
the issue of virtue and and the issue of
the ultimate orientation there's so many
rules that are great but what do you
think is probably if if somebody was to
read those books and there's one rule
that you like this rule out of the 24
I've given you over these past few years
I you can absolutely not get this one
wrong which rule would that be
tell the truth or at least don't lie
because you can't tell the truth right
because who are you to tell the truth
that's a that's a mighty tall order man
but you can stop saying things that you
know are lies and that will change your
life
if you do that and it's crazy how would
it change in your life
well how can you adapt to reality when
you falsify it
you think well I'm just lying to other
people no you're not
you can't just lie to other people
because what you say becomes you
especially if you practice it because we
build ourselves out of words
and that can be lies in action too it's
like don't don't say things you know to
be false that's a that's a good start
man and it aligns yourself with the
truth and that like how can that be a
bad idea imagine that what is true
reflects reality which is sort of the
definition of true how can
failing to align yourself with reality
work how is that possibly going to work
well you say well I can you know if I
lie I get away with something it's like
no you don't
you know I I tell you I swear this is
true
in all of my clinical practice
I have never ever seen anyone ever get
away with anything even once
you think the chickens won't come home
to roost it's like
all that that means is you're too stupid
to see what your lies caused or too
blind or too self-deceptive you just
don't see it
and so you don't get away with anything
nothing it's terrifying to actually
understand that
it's terrifying
what if you can't get away with anything
ever you know well that's the judgmental
God fundamentally that's a very old idea
and it's an old idea for a reason and of
course you can't get away with anything
because imagine that you took a
flexible plastic comb you know when you
bent it backwards and you say well
I got away with that it's like well
what's going to happen when you let go
it's going to snap back and hit you in
the face and that's that's life man you
warp the structure of reality you think
you are someone who can warp the
structure of reality with your words and
get away with it really
no man that should that should terrify
you right to the core of your soul
you're not God your perceptual
structures are determined by the goals
that you have at hand I mean some of
that's that's not completely true
because your perceptual systems also
have limitations right there's things
you can't see or hear even if you need
to so there are limitations built in but
within that set of limitations you're
still trying to tune your perceptions to
your motivated goals and that's also
very useful to think about when you're
trying to understand artificial
intelligence because for human beings
without goals there's no perception
because there's no filtering mechanism
that you can use to determine the level
of resolution at which you perceive
anyway so there's the there's a thing
made of smaller things which are made
out of smaller things and it's so it's
kind of my iconic representation of the
complexity of the world and then you
could think well what is this how can
you see this object and I think if you
just look at it you can detect it's like
a Necker Cube you know those Cube tubes
that that are line drawings that you can
see the front of and then it'll flip to
the back have you seen those so this is
kind of Necker Cube like or at least it
is for me in that when I look at it
my perceptions play around with it
sometimes I focus on the kind of
cross-like shape in the middle and
sometimes I can see these other lines
and then sometimes I'll focus on that
square and sometimes I can see the
little dots there maybe one dot and my
perceptions are going like this trying
to fit a pattern to it and I you can
kind of detect that when you're watching
it and so I would say well you have the
options of perceiving this in its full
complexity or you can simplify it
essentially there's lots of ways you can
simplify it but some of them are laid
out there so you take the complex thing
you make a low resolution representation
of it so that's it's rough that's the
rough area that all those dots occupy
that's the rough area broken down to its
four most fundamental quadrants that
might be how you would look at it if if
this was a map of an orchard and you
were trying to walk from south to North
that would be a useful representation
this combines this and this that's the
that's the highest level of resolution
that you can perceive this object at
that's lower resolution than the object
itself
so the first issue is how should you
look at things well that's a problem
that intelligence has to solve so that's
one of the problems that intelligence
goes after and then I think what happens
is we have the thing in itself and then
we simplify it with a perception
and that's like an iconic representation
and then we we nail the iconic
representation with a word and that's
how we compress the world's complexity
into something that we can manage we
take the complex thing make it into an
icon and represent the icon with a word
and then when I throw you the word so to
speak you decompose it into the icon and
then decompose it even further into the
thing if you can't if you know the icon
and you know the thing and so then we
can use shorthand right because you have
representational structures and so do I
and I'm just tossing you markers about
your representational structures and you
can unfold them that's what you do when
you're reading a novel because the novel
comes alive in your imagination in your
own idiosyncratic way and it wouldn't if
you didn't understand the references of
the novel right the novelist has to
assume that your basic perceptual
structures and your intuitions and your
instincts are basically the same as his
or hers because otherwise they have to
assume that because otherwise they would
be lost in an infinite regressive
explanation
so and it's problematic often for
example if you start reading Victorian
novels you may find that it takes a
while to get into them because the
presuppositions the expectations are
slightly different and so is the
language you have to update the
representations you have to make a
decision in your life and this is
this is a decision and I would say that
it's a voluntary element of Faith
because it isn't exactly evidence-based
it's more like something you decide
before you even look at the evidence
it's more like you decide to stake your
life on this like you know if you decide
to get married to someone you don't
really do it on the basis of the
evidence that you're going to have a
happy life because you don't have that
evidence you do it you decide that
you're going to make a happy life with
this person and that it's worth the risk
so you you get married as an expression
of faith
okay and and so Faith doesn't mean
believing things that no one with any
sense would believe Faith sometimes
means putting a stake in the sand and
saying here is where I stand
in some sense regardless and you do that
when you get married you do that maybe
when you you know pledge allegiance to a
friend you have a best friend and you
want to maintain that friendship as long
as you possibly can it's it's it's a
decision of Faith
um maybe you do that when you decide a
career when you go to university because
you could have done something else right
but you chose that so that's where you
put your faith
um and like I said that doesn't mean
believing what no reasonable person
would believe okay so back to God is
love well I'm going to talk about being
first instead of God
um and being is the totality of
experience that we're going to Define
that it that way for the purposes of
this discussion
being is what there is instead of
nothing and you experience that as a
conscious creature being is what you
experience as a conscious creature it
includes all your emotions all your
motivations all your subjective
experience as well as everything that's
objective Okay so
it seems to me that all things
considered it's a useful
move of Faith to act as if you love
being and if you love something then you
want the best in it to flourish and so
maybe you decide deep in your soul that
it would be better for you to act
towards an end that makes everything
that's good better that that's the best
way to live to make everything that's
good better and maybe to restrict the
development of everything that's
malevolent and evil within yourself and
in the broader world insofar as you're
able to do that and so I think that's an
expression of Love is that because when
you love something you care for it and
the proper attitude towards being I
think is care
and so so that's one element of God is
love God being
analogous in some way to being
um now we could look at God more
classically as the creator of being if
you assume being is good well it's not
much of a leap to assume the creator of
being is good and maybe you adopt an
attitude towards the creator of being
and that's also love and you open your
heart to existence and maybe that's the
most effective means of having existence
open it's heart to you so for example
you know if you love other people you
want the best for them you want the best
and you deserve the best in them if you
love them and you trust them
courageously so you open yourself up to
them I don't think it's unreasonable to
assume that that's how you elicit the
best from them the best that can be
elicited you're going to get hurt
sometimes and betrayed but that's going
to happen no matter what approach you
take I think that's the most effective
approach and that is perhaps the most
effective approach to existence per se
to approach it with love and courage and
and so that's how that looks to me
is it a feeling like loving a person yes
I think it is I think it is a feeling
like loving a person it's it's the
generalization of that care that you
would have for a child your child your
your brother your sister a family member
it's the generalization of that to the
broader domain of of existence to
broader domain of domains of existence
and I think that's a skill in some sense
right I mean if you're good at loving
and caring for your family but you can
expand that outward so that more people
are brought under that umbrella then
well assuming you can manage that it's
very difficult
it seems to me that that's laudable that
seems to me that we spontaneously admire
and would like to imitate people who are
capable of that and so you see that when
you have a job or you and you encounter
a boss who takes you under his or her
wing and helps develop you or you find a
teacher who's particularly inspiring or
you work for an entrepreneur who's
inspiring and who also opens doors for
you
um they're acting with love as far as
I'm concerned they want the best in them
to serve the best in you and that's very
very motivating for everyone and that's
the proper basis of our social
relationships not power for God's sake
so can love balance out the crushing
responsibility that's a sophisticated
question
I don't know the answer to that
love is warmer than responsibility love
is the is part of empathy and
agreeableness it's a different dimension
than responsibility which is more part
of conscientiousness and sort of a cold
virtue I don't know if it balances out
the crushing responsibility but I think
it's the emotional analog to the
crushing responsibility right so maybe
there's love and Duty and they run
parallel in in if you're an ethical
person that's not all there is to ethics
but you know love and Duty they're
they're important and and maybe they're
better together than they would be as
independent
um entities then you could imagine
I have this Cottage
in Northern Ontario and
we're fortunate
uh it's dark there and so you can go
down to the dock at night and in the
clear sky you can see the vast array of
the infinite Heavens The Raid above you
you know and it's something that people
who live in cities really don't get to
experience anymore they don't experience
the sunset which we also go out on our
boat and watch pretty much every day
and that puts you in in touch with what
inspires awe
now when that's not a propositional
experience that's a pre-propositional
experience and it's it's a deep
biological experience it's in it's
embedded in the prey response to a
predator in part you know because if you
if you feel awe sometimes you can feel
that with music a lot of people are high
in openness to experience will feel that
quite frequently under the effect of
aesthetic experiences interestingly
enough their hair stands on in that's
pilo erection that's what a cat does
when it's frightened by a dog like the
little boy at the beginning of the story
you know the cat puffs up to look big to
be like medic hat so that it can contend
with it can contend with dogs or at
least it can look like it might and so
when when it sees a dog the sight of the
dog calls the best fourth out of the cat
well that's what happens when you look
at the night sky
you know
it calls to you
right Dr Dawkins sent me a paper last
week in preparation for a discussion
that we're going to have tomorrow and it
was a very interesting paper and I think
I read it about 25 years ago and he said
any functioning animal has to be a
microcosm a model of the environment
within within which it finds itself
well
that's true of us
and so when you look at the night sky
and
that
sense of awe grips you and calls
something out of you right to respond to
your encounter with the infant and even
your encounter with mortality your
encounter with finitude and limitation
all of that in relationship to the
infinite
that sense of awe is also the calling
forth of something out of you that can
respond to the challenge of that
infinite
well that's the microcosm within no it's
a reflection of the structure of the
cosmos itself
that's the Divine ideal
and we either imitate that or we fail to
imitate that or we pursue the opposite
path
those are the options you know and it's
given our technological power and our
capacity for wholesale atrocity it's
time we woke up and realized it it's
like you really are your only comparison
group especially as you get older
because your life is so idiosyncratic
and peculiar that any compare I mean
look you have to care what other people
think it's stupid to think otherwise
because because you have to be social
and you have to be aware of what other
people are doing and all of that so
it's this is a psychopathic individual
individuality but it is genuinely true
that no one has your set of
opportunities and limitations
and so the the comparison just isn't
real it can't be sufficiently
multi-dimensional you know because maybe
you see someone who's rich I've dealt
with I've I've met many people who are
very very rich and
you can look at their lives and they
have these huge houses and material
plenty but J and they're shielded from
many catastrophes that would hit someone
without those resources harder but
their lives are still full of exactly
the same troubles
that characterize human life in general
and so you you compare yourself on one
dimension you don't see while the
person's worked 80 hours a week for 40
years and it's blown all his
relationships out of the water it's like
yes he's rich but he's also old now
you know only 60 and one of the best
predictors of wealth is age you know
really do you want to be young and poor
or old and Rich it's like I'd pick young
and poor because you can't buy youth
and so and and that's something that's
worth considering but you don't know
what burdens the people you're jealous
of are carrying
so leave it be
it's not it's not helpful to you to to
to be envious if you know what you want
then you know when you're failing
if you don't allow yourself to know what
you want you can keep that foggy
um if you don't set out the conditions
for your success then you can avoid your
responsibility because again that's not
clear and the problem with wanting
something is that in all probability
you're going to have to work for it
you're going to have to make sacrifices
and it's certainly possible that you
want to avoid that
um
you you might be afraid to make it clear
because other people could deny it to
you too which is something I write about
a fair bit in that chapter
um the problem is and and
failing to make any of that clear
protects you right now
but it's really hard on you over the
medium to long term because if you don't
make it clear to yourself what you want
or to other people the probability that
you're just going to stumble into it is
pretty low
and and you can put that off
indefinitely day after day but the
problem with that is that you age while
you're doing that and
there's a obviously a price to be paid
for that so that chapter that's chapter
three do not hide things in the fog
I mean it's a it's a warning about
failing to pay attention
you know knowledge emerges in a very
strange way it it emerges
obviously when we learn something we
started out by not knowing it and so
what that means is that knowledge goes
through a transformation process from
being absolutely not there to being
explicit and fully detailed and one step
of that process is emotion and so for
example you might find yourself
frustrated disappointed about the events
of the day but be unable to exactly
specify why that's extremely common you
know you go home to your partner and you
be in a bad mood and you know you'll
snap at them for something and they'll
say well what's up with you and you'll
say well nothing you're just being
annoying when it's perfectly clear to
both of you that there is actually
something up with you and then that
disappointment and frustration anger and
sadness let's say or anxiety is a sign
that something isn't right but it isn't
like it isn't necessarily that you're
repressing knowledge of what's not right
it's that you just you actually don't
know and the emotion is the first step
in the process by which that knowledge
emerges and you might have to sit and
think and talk to your partner or to a
friend for God only knows how long
before you're actually going to put your
finger on what it is that you're upset
about and it could be very far removed
from whatever happened to trigger you in
the moment and so that's the fog and you
can keep things in the fog just by not
doing that it's really easy it's no diff
more difficult than just sitting there
doing nothing because creating knowledge
is active and difficult well the best
advice that you can really give to
people who are young is that unless you
have very good reason not to you should
do what all people have always done
and so what does that mean I when I see
my clinical clients although I'm not
practicing anymore when I saw my
clinical clients I would evaluate their
lives across a number of Dimensions
um did were they immersed in a network
of friendships
did they have a family that could be
their family of birth but also
the family that they've produced their
own husband or wife and children
if they were of an age where that was
appropriate
did they have a career or at least a job
and was their job productive and
um match well with their abilities and
their Ambitions were they educated to
the extent that their intelligence and
curiosity might demand
were they in reasonable physical and
mental health independent of those other
areas all of those things need to be
established and
you don't want to question them so much
that you don't establish them you might
think of yourself as a rebel and someone
who's particularly unique and it's also
it's also possible that you are unique
in one or more ways but but
fundamentally speaking if you don't do
what everyone else does then the
probability that you're abdicating your
responsibility and that you will miss
out on something important is extremely
high
so and you know our culture virtually
every movie that's made for children now
you see this coming out of the Disney
Studios constantly always concentrates
on the special child who's got abilities
that no other child has and is being
crushed by Society into being
you know unpleasantly normal and
and and
there is a fair bit of crushing that
goes along with being socialized because
part of being socialized is to become
like everyone else but you don't want to
um underestimate the benefit of that
it's it's very very difficult to tread
your own path and you're only going to
be able to do that in a limited number
of areas
you blow apart the social routines
um you'll find yourself out there in a
domain of chaos that will overwhelm you
and that's not pleasant you do not want
that and then with regards to your goals
let's say you don't know what to do well
maybe you're high in openness and so
you're pulled in all sorts of directions
or maybe you're low in conscientiousness
or you're confused because you're
anxious or you haven't had any direction
you haven't had good mentoring etc etc
there's lots of reasons well I would say
pick something right pick something a
nameable goal
and then try to implement it and what
will happen is
you'll learn a lot by trying to
implement it and one of the things you
might learn is what the a slightly
better goal might be you know because if
you try something diligently and you
succeed or you fail you're going to
learn from the the effort expanded in
the detailed implementation of the goal
is going to inform you it'll also
transform you physiologically it does
that at a very basic level neural
neurophysiological level
you will be slightly different as a
consequence of the attempt and what
that'll mean is that the next goal you
pick will be a little more suited to you
and so it's this kind of pathway right
it's like maybe the goal you should be
attaining is here but you don't know
that because you're clueless and so you
aim there well it's better than there
and it's not nothing it's not cessation
of movement and you know if you if
you're supposed to go there and you go
here but you walk diligently towards it
you're a little closer once you get to
here than you were here and it's this
oscillating self-corrective process that
leads you to the final star and you have
to be willing to engage in erroneous
experimentation to to manage that but it
is a self-correcting process and so one
of the things I always talk to my
clients about is well
well let's try something
you know and and we'll Reserve to
ourselves the right to alter our
trajectory
and then I would use as a corrective
there because you might say well how do
you know when you're not just giving out
right instead of thinking maybe you need
a different goal and I would say well
you can if you're really concerned about
your proclivity for self-deception you
can enter into a contract with yourself
that you won't replace any goal you've
set with a goal that's easier
and so you can switch your goal but it
has to be a little harder so that you
check yourself against that tendency to
withdraw and avoid and be self-deceptive
and that works like a charm and if you
do that with some degree of diligence
your goals will get better and more
attainable and you'll get happier too
because you don't experience happiness
except in relationship to a goal and
that's really worth knowing you know and
that's another thing to think about too
if your life is meaningless while you're
not pursuing a valued goal I mean you
might be depressed too and sometimes
that can be like an illness you know
something that is really wrong with you
but A good rule of thumb is that if you
find new joy in life
there's a very low probability that
you're pursuing a goal that you regard
intrinsically like in the depths of your
temperament as worthwhile and that's
technically true because we do in fact
experience most of the positive emotion
let's say that's associated with with uh
with emotions like joy we experience
that in relationship to a goal
so well then you want to find a goal
that regulates your negative emotion and
that brings you a certain amount of
positive emotion and that expands your
competence as you pursue it and you will
experience that as meaningful that's
really what meaning signals meaning
signals you're doing all those things
you say well that's not real it's like
don't listen to the semantic Chatterbox
so much
right there's levels of you that are far
wiser than that and you can watch what
happens to you instead of noticing what
you think on that point of understanding
my inadequacies or someone's
inadequacies I really believe
um that it's really difficult to undergo
self-development if you don't have
self-awareness and I was I was really
trying to understand from your writings
how someone is to build their
self-awareness it's almost like the
unknown unknown if you don't have it how
do you build the thing I know a good
exercise for that
It's Like a Prayer in some sense in fact
I would say it's proper prayer if you
want to know something about yourself
sit on your bed one night and say to
yourself you got to mean this like you
got to be desperate this is no game this
it's like
my life is not everything I wanted to be
and perhaps it's not everything that I
need it to be and by need I mean my life
is so unbearable that
the suffering that's attended upon that
is make me nihilistic cynical bitter
resentful homicidal genocidal unable to
have a good relationship Pro prone to
punish people for their virtues because
of my jealousy
uh driving the proclivity to see evil
everywhere except within my own Heart
Like These are problems man
and you ask yourself you sit on the bed
and say okay man I'm ready to
learn something like what what's one
thing I'm doing wrong that I know I'm
doing wrong that I could fix that I
would fix it's like you meditate on that
you'll get an answer and it won't be one
you want but it'll be the necessary one
you know and it's often
something that will point you to small
things
so Carl Jung said people in the modern
worlds don't see God because they don't
look low enough
and so imagine you're in your messy
bedroom
you know and you're sitting on the edge
of the bed trying to have an honest
dialogue with yourself and the little
voice says
you know it's pretty disgusting in here
and you think well I'm way above Such
trivial niceties as organizing my room
it's like
well that's Pride that's arrogance
if you're above
organizing what's actually yours how in
the world are you ever going to organize
anything else and so you get on your
knees and you think
well it's time to you know
take a brush to the toilet
and maybe that's where you start
and so and that works like that works
you start making those micro
improvements like real micro
improvements real on the ground actual
micro improvements to things you know
that are wrong you'll improve
unbelievably rapidly well I'm not sure
there is an epidemic any more than there
always has been I know that there is now
a tilt towards drugs in in the US in
particular like meth and and
um Fentanyl and the other opiates and
that's quite a catastrophe
um
a lot of that is occurring among people
who don't have
meaning in their lives I would say you
might think that's a facile answer but
it's not you know like here here's the
rat Literature Like It's if you take a
Rat Lab Rat typical lab rat is you know
genetically Brad uh
to be identical with many other lab
routes and he lives alone in a cage and
he he's got a pretty miserable route
life because rats are social animals and
they don't like to live in cages by
themselves and you can get a lab rat in
a cage addicted to cocaine in no time
flat and he'll he'll like press a lever
for cocaine reward pretty much to the ex
to the exclusion of all else including
sex and often including food but if you
take that same rat and you put them in a
rat family you know in a rat social
hierarchy in a rat environment and give
them something that rat rat like to do
so that he can be satisfied it's very
difficult to get him addicted to cocaine
and so I would say the reason that
people take psychomotor stimulants and
all the drugs of serious abuse are
psychomotor stimulants regardless of
what else they might be they activate
the dopaminergic system which is the
system that tracks reward and that that
is associated that's activated when you
pursue valuable goal directed Behavior
if you don't have that if you don't have
a valid goal if you don't have and
there's no no real valid meaning in your
life you don't have a valid ambition
then you don't have any way of
activating that system and why the hell
wouldn't you take drugs it's like you
have to have something better to do to
not addict yourself you know so so I
would say that a huge part of the
current epidemic in in the U.S in
particular is is Manifest among broken
men who have no real place in society
and providing them with money isn't
going to help that they need a
productive and meaningful existence and
which is the Paramount the Paramount
goal should be the Paramount goal of
social of social policy for example we
it isn't the alleviation of poverty
that's really the issue because people
in the west aren't poor there might be a
bit of a distribution problem but we're
not poor what we have is a
so uh what would you say a
we have a problem of meaningful
engagement and that's what has to be
addressed and that's why I do the work
that I'm doing how much do people have
to kind of date around to find somebody
though because it does take a bit of
exploration to find somebody you're
compatible with so what's a reasonable
amount of exploration and like by what
age should people have figured it out
because I mean there's always the grass
looks Greener so at some point maybe you
should just settle down but what are
your thoughts on that
laughs
well life isn't very long
and so you don't get to evaluate that
many relationships you probably only
have a five to ten year period to do
that something like that and then the
reason you only have that amount of time
is because it gets more and more
difficult as you get older rather than
easier partly because people your age
are increasingly in relationships so I
would say get at it don't don't
overestimate the degree to which you
have to find someone versus
create the relationship you know there's
many cultures and I'm not I'm not
suggesting that this is necessarily a
desirable alternative
but there are many cultures that arrange
marriages and those arranged marriages
frequently work it's not obvious that
they work less frequently than
relationships or marriages that are
predicated on romantic attraction
which has its own pitfalls
is that no matter who you find there are
going to be full of flaws like you are
and so a lot of it is something you
create I think you want to find someone
you can trust and someone that you're
attracted to and perhaps someone who
shares the same ambitions
as you do or at least has Ambitions that
are compatible with yours and then
well then pretty much all of it after
that is what you create rather than what
you find is part of the reason that
arranged relationships or arranged
marriages work is part of it because
there's a societal pressure to not get
divorced and because it's somebody your
parents have chosen there might be an
expectation that you're supposed to
uphold of course I mean that's partly
why marriages in the west work too or
marriages and cultures where
the primary impetus for the marriage is
romantic or sexual attraction part of
the reason those marriages works is
because work is because of social
pressure
it it's very difficult to sustain a
relationship across time and you need
all sorts of social institutions
as well as conceptual schemes operating
to help ensure that that's the case
because life is so difficult you're
going to go through periods of time
where your relationship is
extraordinarily difficult but there's no
escaping that and
if the pressure to stay together wasn't
there the relationship might fragment
prematurely and then Not only would you
have your problems you'd also not have
any relationships and that's not helpful
so you go through thick and thin
together and it can be very thin the
thin times can be very thin
but
that the collective Judgment of the
human race so far has been that
long-term monogamous relationships are
the best that you can manage
and that's true cross-culturally with
there are exceptions polygamy is is
relatively common nowhere near as common
as monogamy but there are exceptions
made for polygamy but
the problem with polygamous societies is
that they tend to be more violent
especially the young men in them tend to
be more violent because they are more
Shut Out Of The Mating Game and that
makes them very frustrated oh that makes
sense so it'd be mostly yeah that makes
sense that'd make me pissed off too why
is this why is this guy over here have
seven wives he'd be better off dead yes
yes and I might be the one to help them
along with that yeah I mean that's part
of what monogamy does is stabilize
societies and that means that fewer
stable in stable societies fewer people
die and so
All Things Considered our species has
decided that that's a good trade-off how
is it the discipline and the straight
and narrow offer the best chance for a
good life and and how is it that we have
forgotten that is the case
well the reason that discipline is
necessary is because you're a massive
competing short-term interests
and so the question is then well which
short-term interest should win out and
the answer to that is well none of them
they need to be organized into a
hierarchy
that makes them functional across time
and across individuals so like a
two-year-old is very likely to act out
his or her proximal impulse but of
course a two-year-old can't survive in
the world
you have to Reagan you have to bring
your your primary instincts let's say
under the regulatory structure of a
higher order value system that allows
them to manifest themselves without
undo Mutual sacrifice across large spans
of time in the presence of large numbers
of other people so that requires a very
sophisticated ordering it's like we
already talked about the fact that a
metanarrative is necessary to unite
subcultures say so that they can operate
peacefully and harmoniously within the
same space the same thing applies within
you because you're like an you're an
internal Coalition of Warring
single-minded tribes and they have to
all be brought under the organizational
structure of long-term Collective Vision
let's say and in order to do that you
have to be disciplined and any
discipline speaking you know technically
speaking is an attempt to bring all
those competing short-term impulses
under a large a larger scale and more
inclusive framework
and so you do that and then well that's
actually what gives you freedom
being impulsive and being free aren't
the same things because if you're
impulsive you're just the slave of your
impulses right there's no freedom in
that that's that's just that's the same
Freedom so to speak literally that a
two-year-old house because a
two-year-old isn't socialized yet so
it's not it's a completely
it that doesn't function in this in a
sophisticated World it doesn't work
right everyone knows it my father gave
me an Abiding and then the other thing I
should say about him is he spent a
tremendous amount of time with me when I
was very young say before I was five or
six he taught me to read he did that
every night for months and I remember
that very vividly and instilled in me a
love of books and a fluency in Reading
um
he
believe that I could do
what I set my mind to
and he really believed that and to have
someone that believe that of you that's
something man and you know it was
something that I wanted to offer to my
clinical clients you know because I did
believe that
there was more to them than the
suffering person that was sitting there
and that you know with joint diligent
effort we could sift our way through the
chaff and find the wheat and that things
could be better and one of the lovely
things about practicing as a clinician
was that that was that almost inevitably
happened and sometimes really radically
and and then of course later it started
started happening on a broader scale and
I was seeing that happen in the lives of
maybe thousands of people and so
wherever I go in the world people come
up to me and they're usually
I wouldn't say they're happy to see me
they're often in tears
you know
and they often have a pretty rough story
to relate you know they were suicidal or
nihilistic or homicidal or
trapped desperate
you know and they tell me that real fast
and then they say I've overcome that to
a large degree and thank you for that
and
and you think well that's really
something to
have that happen over and over in some
ways you might think well how could
anything better possibly happen to you
than to have people come up to you all
over the world strangers and open
themselves up like that like their old
friends so quickly but at the same time
it's an awful thing
because you see
even in the revelation of their Triumph
the initial depth of their despair
so I wouldn't change that
but it's not nothing
it's certainly not just happiness
it's better than happiness but it's
almost unbearable
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to learn how to stop the
procrastination check the video right
there next to me I think you'll love it
you to believe and I'll see you there
execution the carrying out and putting
into effect of a plan order or course of
action putting it into effect execution
I put it into effect